hey
there welcome welcome welcome this is
answering adventism where we are
raising the general consciousness of the
Christian church as it pertains to the
cultic doctrines of 7th Day adventism
equipping as many Christians as possible
to reach as many sth day Adventists as
possible with the true Christ and his go
El so thank you for being here
especially if this is your first time
with us Adventist or otherwise we are
back with part two we are going to
finish up what we started last week
listening to a sermon from SDA Pastor
Steph bore uh where he talked about and
laid out some of the key aspects of 7th
Day Adventist theology namely 1844 the
investigative judgment and the Priestly
role of Christ in part two we are going
to be transitioning into his
presentation or rather the SDA Church's
uh official position on the close of
probation Michael the Archangel standing
up the scapegoat and a number of other
topics here and there um and I emphasize
the sda's official teaching component of
that because if you're a Christian you
have to understand that um there are
going to be lots of Adventists that are
going to try and dismiss the individual
that we will be listening to tonight
they'll try and say things like oh he's
one of those hyper conservative yada
yada types um no Steven bore is just a
consistent Seventh Day Adventist he
actually understands the system of
Theology and doesn't try to cherry-pick
or alak cart he takes it all um at least
as I've seen so this is not anything
about Steven bour personally he is
simply serving as an example but before
getting into that a couple of
housekeeping items uh for those of you
that are new I have to preface this is
going to be
long this is going to be long you may
need to take notes you might need to
take it in bite-size amounts but this
will be a rather lengthy presentation
which will require focus and diligence I
know that um it isn't long presentations
like this that perform the best on
YouTube so be it we are seeking to be
faithful to our mission which is
publicly stated which is to equip as
many Christians as possible to reach as
many seventhday Adventists as possible
and if you're serious about that it
requires getting your hands dirty and
really inspecting under the uh
theological Hood if you will which leads
me to my next point I want to remind
everyone excuse me both Adventists and
non-adventist alike what the purpose of
these streams are we get lots and lots
and lots of Adventists that have zero
clue what this platform is
about this platform like I said in the
in the opening is about raising the
general consciousness of the body of
Christ to the deceptive nature of SDA
theology without having a great
controversy worldview it will be hard
for a Christian to decipher what all is
being said so I seek to function as a
translator if you will to help bridge
that Gap and connect the dots for both
Christians former Adventists and heck
even current Adventists for that matter
highlighting the differences of what is
being said when things are either vague
or sound like standard Christian e let
me be uh very clear
here this platform does not consider
seventh adventis adventism to be
Christian notice I said seventh day
adventism not sth day
Adventists Adventists tend to identify
their identity around seventh day
adventism
ISM not just being a Seventh Day
Adventist
so this platform is not about various
individuals or about playing elect
detector this platform is about sounding
the alarm to wake up both Christians and
Adventists alike to this organization's
deceptive doctrines to strengthen the
body of Christ that I love and equip us
on the spiritual Battlefield to be ready
to go into the fire and pull these
people out who have been
deceived so that needs to be understood
for all the Adventists that are going to
comment down below all these sorts of
things you you're wasting your time you
don't understand why this platform
exists why we're here I'm wearing red
folks this is indicative of uh how
tonight's going to be I might get a
little fiery if you will what else is
new
but when a movement claims that our
Eternal Destiny hinges on accepting
their novel
system which purports to be the
theological God Particle The Theory of
Everything direct access to the mind of
God their words not mine not mine
Adventist those are not my
words those are your representatives
words yeah you bet we're going to be
hypercritical and I'm not the one in the
wrong for
that if you claim to have the Anvil that
can wear out any Hammer then you should
be more than welcoming of
critique when you make what might be one
of the most if not the most grandiose
claim in all of human
history you are going to be analyzed
with a fine tooth comb and investigated
meticulously to check this claim I
didn't say it they did speaking of which
let's get back into
this now let's go to Revelation 15 and
verses 5-8 Revelation 15 veres 5-8 now
let me just mention that at this point
the Three Angels messages have been
proclaimed climed you know the Three
Angels messages are God's last message
to the world they're found in Revelation
14 and: 6 through 12 as long as the
three messages are being preached the
door of probation is open but the time
is coming when the door of probation is
going to
close
Okay so right out of the gate this is
foundational to the rest it's
foundational to everything he said last
week as well but it's foundational to
everything else that he is going to be
saying moving forward for some of
you this is going to be a
repeat but we have to get into this okay
for those that are new they may not have
seen
this before we hear their interpretation
of Revelation 15 Christian it is
important that you understand what all
is meant by what he just said he said
the Three Angels messages are God's last
message to the world
why does he say this right before
seeking to explain the SDA teaching of
the close of
probation first notice the SDA Church's
mission
statement quote Make Disciples of Jesus
Christ who live as his loving Witnesses
and Proclaim to all people the
Everlasting Gospel of the Three Angels
messages
in preparation for his soon return close
quote so if you want to be
prepared for Christ's return you have to
embrace the SDA Church's special message
which is really a world
view that is called the Great
controversy
theme that's the formal name for
it that is the product that this
business is
selling because that's what the SDA
movement is that's what SDA trademark
symbol is it's a business it is a
money-making
Ruckus and their product is the unique
worldview that they have you slowly
adopt over
time and most are doing so unknowingly
it's like a fish in water how do you
explain to it that it's in water it's
like all it knows that's what happens
here
you adopt this Paradigm and worldview
that does not come from the Bible we've
looked at this
before Herbert Douglas Ministry magazine
2000 he shoots it straight they were
given this worldview they did not
Discover it he says it did not come from
reading the Bible and then oh well this
is just our understanding of of what's
being said here no no no no it came from
outside of the Bible and is brought to
the Bible
which is what then defines the Three
Angels in Revelation 14 Adventists will
point to this and say see there's three
Angels here in Revelation 14 and that's
supposed to mean all the things that
we're about to see here moving forward
so understand
that but that's the mission of the SDA
Church to take what they have read into
Revelation 14 to the world so what all
do they P into the
text notice what FD nickel laed mident
7th Adventist
apologist what he said in their Church
paper the review and Herald from
November 25th
quote the prime reason why we must stand
apart is found in the second of the
Three Angels messages whose coraly is
revelation 18
1-4 there we read come out of her my
people we speak often of the third
Angel's message what we all what we
always should say is the Three Angels
messages all three messages are
significant and will continue to be so
till the end of
time the second Angel joined his voice
with the first and the third with the
two preceding and the three-fold Cry of
warning sounds forth to all the world
until probation closes
the three messages are of the very heart
of the message we bring to the
world the Seventh
Adventist the chief reason for our
existence as a separate
people they're not Christian they're
separate from Christians they have their
own message their own unique thing that
they're doing but they'll want to tell
you no no no we're
Christians now they have a different
message than the Christian church that
only they have that's what this supposed
Three Angels messages is he
continues in the name of calm reason how
could we in one breath say let us join
talking about other Christians and in
the next breath say come out of her my
people the answer is we could not
if ever it was necessary that we should
understand the reason for our existence
and why it is that we must stand apart
that time is now close
quote from an article in their paper
with the title of ecumenical movement
grows so notice what he
mentions the claim that the third
Angel's message bounds forth to all the
world until probation closes but really
all three of the messages
this same thing we just heard from
Steven
bour so the SDA Church claims to be
represented by the Three Angels in
Revelation 14 as the ones heralding the
messages and he says that's their chief
reason for their existence as a separate
people but as you can see this is
supposedly why they stand out from
everyone else and why they must see
themselves as entirely distinct from
Christians as the true ones it's part of
the DNA of
adventism so don't fall for this idea
that oh we're just like you brother
they're just another Christian
denomination amongst others with a
couple theological quirks no they're not
the PE that doesn't mean the people are
bad people I'm not saying
that heck administ are actually great
people but this evidence is they're not
part of the Christian Church they have a
different mission with a different
message than the message of the
Christian
church again same paper
notice three years prior May 3rd
1962 quote The Remnant alone has
preached The Three Angels messages of
Revelation 14 for more than a century
calling attention to the judgment and
warning against the worship of the Beast
it alone accepted the spirit of Prophecy
as a divinely inspired commentary on the
Bible so for all the AVST out there
that'll tell you no no we don't claim
the spirit of Prophecy is Ellen White's
writings yeah
okay that's what they mean here by
Spirit of Prophecy folks the writings of
Ellen White which are supposedly the
divinely inspired commentary on the
Bible it alone takes the Bible as the
only guide and excludes all traditions
and unbiblical doctrines close quote
Yeah except for you know your entire
worldview which is foreign to the Bible
that you've brought to the Bible and
doesn't come from the Bible and is
literally just a massive
tradition but numerous times we've
looked at sources that say this exact
same thing you have to understand the
Adventist Church calls their unique
gospel message The Three Angels
messages and here you see they say only
they are preaching this message no one
else and it's what they call present
truth that must be believed for this
time and this message is what will have
you prepared for Jesus's
return but also notice part of this
package deal is the spirit of
Prophecy which is a catchphrase like I
said to refer to Ellen White's writings
they climb that the spirit of Prophecy
is the testimony of Jesus Revelation
1910 and Jesus is speaking through her
writings Argo they contain the spirit of
Prophecy and this then gives them a
divinely inspired commentary on
scripture which unlocks what's really
being said On Any Given
passage and it was also through this
alleged Spirit of Prophecy that the
great controversy worldview was given to
them one once again same paper November
18 1862 husband of the prophetess James
White quote another scene and another
chain of prophetic events is introduced
in these verses we here have what is
known as The Three Angels messages of
Revelation
14 the first Angel is called another
Angel because John had already seen one
flying in a similar
manner CH uh Revelation chap 18 or 818
he proclaims the gospel not a now one
but the Everlasting gospel that actually
should say new I think it was actually a
typo in the review in Herald but
nevertheless it's not a new one but the
Everlasting gospel as it's called in
Matthew 24:14 the Gospel of the Kingdom
remember part
one but while it is the same
gospel there are particular features
which constitute the burden of the
message Chief among which is shown by
verse 7 is The Nearness of the
Kingdom this message cannot therefore
symbolize the preaching of the Gospel by
the
apostles nor by the reformers nor by any
class of people except those who live
when the end is just at hand the Advent
Proclamation especially
from 1840 to
1844 completely answers to the prophecy
and is the only great religious movement
which can be pointed to as its
fulfillment close
quote now what did we talk about in part
one the kingdom of
God and we saw how their timeline of
God's kingdom being inaugurated is
severely off
but as you now see this is intimately
tied with 1844 the investigative
judgment their interpretation of Daniel
7 Etc the close of probation The Three
Angels messages all this stuff is
interconnected and it's why the SDA
Church will die on every single one of
these Hills notice James White says the
third Angel proclaims the gospel but not
a new one it's the Everlasting gospel
which is the gospel of the kingdom and
in part one we heard Steven bore tell us
that Jesus began the investigative
judgment in 1844 to receive his kingdom
after determining who is and isn't part
of it and the kingdom is only the
people so that means the investigative
judgment is a part of the SDA Church's
gospel and no one else proclaims this
message or the or the doctrine and no
one before them was heralding it not the
apostles not the reformers not the
patristics
Etc this is why he said that this
message is God's Last Day message to
Earth the final
message it's why the mission statement
had it in the mission this is why the
door of probation is open right now
supposedly it makes salvation possible
the door closes when it's no longer
being shared and salvation is no longer
available because salvation is tied to
believing this message
it is vital to understand this when
seeking to understand SDA theology they
have their own Gospel it's not the
Christian Gospel they can use all the
same words and and we believe in Jesus
we believe in the gospel we believe that
means
nothing that that means
nothing this is what they actually mean
by those words and if you go read that
article by Herbert Douglas Ministry
magazine December 2000 he says the great
controversy theme is what defines all
those
words they have their own Gospel as
James White tried to tack on it's the
same gospel it's not a new one but
there's particular features that
constitute it that are
unique no that's 100% double speak
classic SDA double speak it is not the
same not in any way shape or
form do not lose sight of this do not
lose sight of this notice Revelation
15:
5-8 do you remember that we read once
before in Revelation 11:19 that the
temple of God was opened in heaven and
the Ark of his Covenant was seen and
that refers to the beginning of the
Judgment could people enter by faith to
follow what Jesus was doing in the most
holy Place absolutely we studied that
but now I want you to notice that the
Temple's going to be opened again
the most holy place is going to be
opened again but this time it's not open
for people to be able to go in by faith
to see what Jesus is doing to sympathize
with his work remember what the people
did on the day of atonement this time it
is opened to let the plague Angels come
out to pour their plagues out upon the
Earth notice Revelation
15:5 after these things I looked and
behold the Temple of the Tabernacle of
the testimony was opened in heaven was
open now I I want you to understand what
the Temple of the Tabernacle of the
testimony is the Tabernacle of the
testimony is the
tent it's called The Tabernacle the holy
and the most holy place but what is the
Temple of the Tabernacle the Temple of
the Tabernacle is the most holy place so
what is being opened here the most holy
place of the Heavenly sanctuary and now
notice verse 6 and out of the
temple what out of the temple came the
seven angels having seven plags clothed
in pure bright linen and having their
chests girded with golden Bands then one
of the four living creatures gave to the
seven angels seven golden bowls full of
the wrath of God who lives forever and
ever why is the temple opened it's not
open for people to go in now and be
saved it's opened to let the plague
Angels out has probation closed when the
plagues begin to be poured out
absolutely so this is talking about the
close of human probation now will God's
people be able to enter the most holy
place by faith once this take place
takes place no notice verse eight the
temple that's the most holy place the
temple was filled with smoke from the
glory of God and from his power and no
one was able to what to enter the temple
that's the most holy Place till the
seven plagues of the Seven Angels were
completed are God's people uh the living
Saints are they going to be able to
serve God in the temple day and night
according to the Book of Revelation
after Jesus comes yes but after
probation closes and until the plagues
are all poured out is anybody going to
be able to enter the temple to be saved
to claim Jesus as the mediator or the
intercessor no it says no one was able
to enter the temple till the seven
plagues of the Seven Angels were
completed and the reason why is because
when the seven angels are pouring out
the bowls when they're pouring out the
plages probation has closed Jesus has
finished his ministration and no one can
enter there by faith you say well can we
really enter the most holy place of
course we can we enter by faith don't we
doesn't the bible say that we can draw
draw near to the throne of God in
Hebrews chapter 4 yes we don't do so
physically because it says that this
Temple is in heaven but we do it in our
mind we do it by following Jesus in the
sanctuary in the work that he is
performing all right so he says this
text is speaking about a Heavenly
sanctuary building that is being opened
specifically the most holy Place
Apartment of that building and he's
correct actually that is what John was
shown John has shown a vision in the
Greek regarding the phrase the
Tabernacle of witness refers to the most
holy place but he is in
Vision the idea that everything seen in
vision is 100% literal realities is not
only not true but even the SDA church
and her Scholars recognize this like we
saw in part one Roy gain claimed there
isn't a literal second veil in heaven
that Jesus went behind and entered in
1844 even though that's what Ellen White
saw it was only symbolic and
representative of his changing in
ministerial
function however what Steven bore added
is that this time the most holy place
doesn't open so that people can come in
by faith and be saved but to let the
plague Angels out we will Circle back
around to what Revelation 15 is getting
at in a moment but some important things
to understand
here we already saw in part in part one
why this theory of an identical building
in heaven is flawed but let's roll with
this and Grant them that their theory is
correct there's a building in heaven
like what was on Earth only larger in
scale but it's the exact same layout and
everything two things we need to look at
here for you to grasp what is being said
first when Steven bore says the first
time the most holy place was opened and
points to the beginning of the Judgment
where people entered by faith to follow
Jesus he talked about this a little bit
in the last part because he was talking
about 18 44 But ultimately this is
coming from or rather it's confirmed by
supposedly a vision of Ellen White we've
looked at this in full many times but as
to the relevant
portion early writings starting on page
quote I
saw the father rise from the throne and
in a flaming Chariot go into the holy of
holies within the veil and sit down
then Jesus rose up from the throne and
the most of those who were bowed down
arose with
him I did not see one ray of light pass
from Jesus to the careless multitude
remember
this I did not see one ray of light pass
from Jesus to the careless
multitude after he arose and they were
left the careless multitude in perfect
Darkness those who arose when Jesus did
kept their eyes fixed on him as he left
the throne and led them out a little way
then he raised his right arm and we
heard his lovely voice saying wait here
I'm going to my father to receive the
kingdom keep your garments spotless and
in a little while I will return from the
wedding and receive you to
myself then a cloudy Chariot with wheels
like flaming fire surrounded by Angels
Came To Jesus or came to where Jesus was
he stepped into the Chariot and was born
to the holiest where the father
set then I beheld jesus a great high
priest standing before the
father standing before the father on the
Hem of His Garment was a bell and a
pomegranate a bell and a
pomegranate Those Who Rose up with Jesus
would send up their faith to him in the
holiest and pray my father give us thy
Spirit then Jesus would Breathe upon
them the Holy
Ghost in that breath was light power and
much love joy and
peace I turned to look at the company
that careless multitude who were still
bowed Before the Throne
they did not know that Jesus had left
it Satan appeared to be by the throne
trying to carry on the work of
God I saw them look up to the throne and
pray father give us thy
Spirit Satan would then breathe upon
them an Unholy
influence in it there was light and much
power but no sweet love joy and
peace Satan's object was to keep them
deceived and to draw back and deceive
God's
children close
quote so Ellen White claimed to be shown
in Vision that there were two groups of
people in the Holy place of this
heavenly Tabernacle building both bowed
down before God's throne in that Holy
Place one was the little flock the small
band of millerites that refused to
accept that they were wrong in
1844 and the other the careless
multitude AKA Christians of the day that
rejected
millerism on October 22nd
1844 both the father and the Adventist
Jesus got up off that Throne to move
into the holy place for Jesus to begin
the investigative
judgment ah now she saw him as a high
priest if you recall from part one this
poses serious problems
you'll recall they claimed that until
1844 Jesus was doing analogous work to
the Earthly daily ministration work of
the of the Levites only up in heaven
using his own
blood you'll also recall that Hebrews 9
and Leviticus tell us that the daily
Administration was a standing work not a
seated
one yet here Ellen has Jesus
seated not just SE seated but on a
throne in the Holy
place then he gets up and then he's
standing in the most holy Place
functioning as a priest so when you hear
Adventist try and say that what was on
Earth is an identical copy of what's in
heaven or some will try and use this
argument only it was smaller in scale no
their own propheus describes this
heavenly temple building differently
than what was on
Earth but back to the vision she claims
that when they got up to move the little
flock raised their heads to see this and
followed Jesus by faith into the most
holy Place meaning believing in the
investigative judgment and Sanctuary
teaching what became
that at the time it's just this concept
of well Jesus entered into the most holy
place for the first
time this is early early on before
they've systematized before Bates and
and them have all systematized this
out those that were still bowed down
the Christians of the day they remained
bowed down out in that Holy place and no
light shined on them with regards to
this
change so they were because they
rejected this teaching they were still
out in the Holy place not really
worshiping Jesus anymore because he'd
moved he went to a different town bro
you're in the round wrong town that type
thing Satan then crept in beside the the
throne and was able to breathe an Unholy
influence on
them and the people thinking their
prayers were going to God were actually
going to Satan who kept them in
deception this is what Steven bore means
when he says that the holy place opened
the most holy
place for the first time to allow one to
enter by faith and be
saved you could get into the holy Place
figuratively speaking before 1844 but if
you want to get to that next step the
fifth step in the sda's seven steps
through the sanctuary model of
Salvation you have to now accept the SDA
Church's novel
teaching so you had truth up to that
point and it was fine but in 1844 now
Jesus moved to this next step and if you
don't move with him well you're not
really following
Jesus how convenient right
but the second thing that has to be
understood about this is that he makes
no mention of
them no mention of them claiming that
the door of Mercy was shut multiple
different times between 1844 and
1853 Ellen White initially tied this
change from the holy to the most
holy to the shut door of mercy and that
probation had closed
and she claimed to see this in
vision for
example present truth Magazine August
1st
quote Saturday March 24th 1849 we had a
sweet and very interesting meeting with
the Brethren of topam Main
the Holy Ghost was poured out upon us
and I was taken off in the spirit to the
city of the Living
God there I was shown that the
Commandments of God and the testimony of
Jesus Christ relating to the shut door
could not be
separated and that the time for the
Commandments of God to shine out with
all their importance and for God's
people to be tried on the Sabbath truth
trth was when the door was opened in the
most holy place of the Heavenly
Sanctuary where the ark is containing
the Ten
Commandments this door was not opened
until the mediation of Jesus was
finished in the Holy place of the
sanctuary in
1844 then Jesus rose up and shut the
door in the Holy place and
opened the door in the most holy and
passed within the second Veil where he
now stands by the ark and where the
faith of Israel now reaches close
quote notice the standing aspect in
relation to what we looked at last
week but you have to recognize and
understand this eventually became the
new theory that is still the theory to
this day
oh one door closed but another
opened that was not the initial teaching
it was the door is closed and it's
closed but in her alleged First Vision
documented in word to the little flock
by James White we have looked at how she
says those that rejected
1844 fell off the path of Salvation down
into the wicked world that God had
rejected this eventually changes into
the claim that well the shut door is
true but despite one door shutting
another one
opened so no never mind salvation's
still
possible and this is because
supposedly God had more light to give
before the time of Salvation could be
up no no no we didn't set a false date
we didn't set a false prophecy no no no
we didn't falsely claim the door of
Mercy shut no no no it's always some
cover up and it's God's
fault no no no we weren't wrong about
1843 it's it's 1844 no we weren't wrong
about 1844 it's actually Jesus moved to
the most holy place but the door of
Mercy is shut no no no it's not that the
door of Mercy is shut it's that that
door shut but another one opened present
truth present truth present
truth yeah
okay God still had to give the quote un
quote Sabbath truth before the end could
come and the truth about the Ten
Commandments the real truth about the
Ten Commandments you know because no one
really understood the the the proper use
of the law prior to the SDA Church being
around which is where they are now and
ultimately what Stephen is getting
at probation won't close until the the
you know well a number of things they
say but when this message isn't being
preached
anymore probation Will will have closed
when this message is taken off of the
Earth but he leaves out this
Inconvenient Truth because notice same
issue of the same
paper she
continues God has begun to draw this
covering over his people and it will
very soon be drawn over all who are to
have a shelter in the day of
Slaughter God will work in power for his
people and Satan will be permitted to
work also I
saw that the mysterious signs and
wonders and false reformations would
increase and
spread the reformations that were shown
me were not reformations from error to
truth but from bad to
worse for those who professed a change
of
heart had only wrapped about them a
religious Garb which covered up the
iniquity of a wicked heart
some appeared to have been really
converted so as to deceive God's people
but if their beasts could be
seen they would appear as black as
ever my accompanying Angel bade me look
for the travel of soul for Sinners as
used to be I looked but could not see it
for the time for their salvation is
passed close quote
so in
1849 she's claiming that God was at work
drawing his covering over his people the
little flock because signs and wonders
from Satan were taking place amongst the
Christians of the day Satan was
permitted to bring these about to make
it appear like there was Revival and
understanding amongst the Christian
churches but they were only wrapped in
religious Garb with Wicked
Hearts some seemed to be truly converted
acting like they had a changed heart but
it was a
deception we've looked at the quotes
before she says the ministers were
actually tools of Satan and they use the
word of God appearing like they know
what it's talking about but it's
actually Satan deceiving them and
everyone's coming for this group of 120
people and the angel showed her that the
time for salvation for The Souls of
Sinners was passed
period now notice what da Pioneer Uriah
Smith noticed his defense to this in his
article series The Visions objections
answered which was published over the
course of a month and a half I believe
in review and heral
notice regarding the phrase the time of
their salvation is passed from that
Ellen White quote here's the
defense
quote who's
salvation markw the scene of the vision
is one of the false Revival of these
last
days there are two classes of persons
involved therein namely
Sinners or nonpressor and the
revivalists now which of these classes
constitutes the leading subject of the
view if we can ascertain this we can
tell which class is referred to in the
Declaration the time for their salvation
is past the only reasonable construction
that can be put upon the language as
well as the preceding testimony of the
vision itself seems as plainly as needed
be as need be shown that the false
revivalists are the ones referred to not
Sinners see the first paragraph of page
26 quote I saw that Satan was working
through agents in a number of ways he
was at work through ministers who have
rejected the truth and are given over to
strong delusions to believe a lie that
they might be damned close
quote these ministers are the ones
referred to who are carrying on the
false revivals brought to view she was
bed to look to see if there was on their
part the travail for Souls as used to be
she could not see it
why because they the
ministers had reject rejected the truth
and had been given over to believe a lie
the time for their
salvation the ministers was passed and
they could not feel that deep and
genuine concern for Souls that would be
felt by those who stood in the Council
of God and through whom he was working
to bring Sinners to
himself this plainly
shows that the false revivalists and not
sinners in general are the subject of
that declaration close
quote Yeah Uriah Smith is full of
beans full of
it the careless multitude that was only
pastors these are the same people that
were part of the wicked world that God
had rejected from the first Vision that
they had to alter and remove 30 some odd
words yeah okay
no he is full of it we saw where Ellen
said that Satan made it seem as though
people were converted by the false
revivalists that's supposed to be the
ministers they were the ones that during
these false reformations they appeared
as though they had been converted by the
false reformations that they were
leading
she said it was through these false
reformations led by false ministers that
people appeared to be converted by the
false reformations but they
weren't this is another case of a both
and taking place that is ignored he
starts off with a false dilemma because
there are three options here not just
two she could be referring to only the
sinners
she could be referring to only the
ministers or she could be referring to
both it's obviously
both because the believing at the time
was that the ministers were deceived by
sta by
Satan this group is still bowed down in
the Holy place trying to open that door
that had been shut because you have to
follow Jesus into the most holy place by
faith for salv
that was supposedly the present truth of
the day in this same article she talks
of these ministers trying to open the
door that God had shut and shut the most
holy place
door that they were trying to open the
holy place while shutting the most holy
place by rejecting
1844 since those ministers rejected 1844
they were lost and those who appeared to
be converted under their preaching were
also lost because they didn't have the
present truth on salvation and only
appeared like they had a changed Heart
by these false reformations that were
actually the result of
Satan because a changed heart allegedly
came from the little flocks message and
supposed truth on the Sabbath light or
light on the Sabbath truth and the Ten
Commandments which the Christians
according to them didn't have and were
still bowed down in the Holy place place
where Satan was breathing on them in
Unholy
influence seeing the
connections Satan was allowed to breathe
on them in Unholy
influence those bowed down still before
that throne in the Holy place she saw no
light shine onto them Satan was allowed
to cause false reformations that would
keep them bowed down at that throne and
not see the truth of the 1844 message
they thought were praying to God but
they weren't they had been
rejected it wasn't just ministers bowed
down before the throne he said the
little flock was there bowing down so
their group wasn't only ministers but
the other group that remained bwing down
that's allegedly only Christian
ministers because she says in this word
to the little flock Vision God had
rejected the Wicked World and that those
who believed in the millerite message at
first and went on to realize this is a
shame
they fell off the path into the wicked
world that God had
rejected that's the understanding until
there are changes down the
road this is before those changes that
this stuff is going
on this guy is then writing about this
20 years removed trying to deal with
objections doing the classic SDA rewrite
of History
now this group claimed to exclusively
have the Sabbath truth and the Ten
Commandment truth and evangelism at the
time was
non-existent because that's what they
believed this only changed in the
1850s so nice try but no if your IQ is
above room temperature and you've
studied
this I'm not going to suspend my ability
to critically think and go along with
this
charate this is SDA apologetics to a te
showing you how desperate they are and
will'll request that you suspend your
critical thinking faculties and keep
going along with a sham Uriah Smith
should have been ashamed of himself as
should any other Adventist that tries to
argue this Christians don't let them
insult your intelligence that includes
you former Adventist friend don't let
them insult your intelligence and make
you seem like you're the problem you're
a crackpot no that's part of the SDA
programming
to make you doubt your own common
sense you saw clearly how Ellen White
was referring to not just
ministers people outside of their little
band They allegedly had the present
truth on salvation for the time and the
time of Salvation was passed for others
trust your god-given intellect glorify
him with that as you're called to do by
exercising it and thinking critically
and logically in fact notice in 1845
four years prior to this article in the
present truth that Smith is referring to
this is from Ellen White's alleged
second
Vision so middle of February
supposedly
quote The View about the bridegroom's
coming I had about the middle of
February
1845 while in exer Maine in meeting with
Israel Damon James and many others many
of them did not believe in a shut door
what
year I suffered much at the commencement
of the
meeting unbelief seemed to be on every
hand unbelief about
what the shut
door there was one sister there that was
called very
spiritual she had traveled and been a
powerful
preacher the most of the time for 20
years she had been truly a mother in
Israel but a division had risen in the
band on the shut
door she had great sympathy and could
not believe the door was
shut I had known nothing of their
differences sister Durban got up to talk
I felt very very
sad close
quote so before moving
forward this is in
1845 before the pivot to one door closes
and another
opened this is when the door is outright
closed remember the first Vision those
that fell off the path fell down into to
the
what the wicked world that God had
rejected and those that fell off aka the
millerites that rejected
1844 it was impossible she says for them
to get back on the
path the Christians of the day were
lumped in as not even being considered
to be on the path they'd rejected the
message so they weren't on the path but
then the millerites that eventually lost
you know hope in this nonsense those are
the ones that fell off the path
allegedly and it was impossible for them
to get back on the path they were now
down in the dark world that included the
Christians that weren't even on the path
to begin with but this lady sister
Durban was known to be a powerful
preacher that traveled around she says
not a new convert to their
movement and she says divisions had
developed regarding the shut door belief
of which Ellen said that she wasn't
aware of these
differences so then she hears about
these these differences and then
documents down essentially her response
to this one side was saying the door is
shut for good the other was saying no it
can't
be sister Durban was one of those she
had great Sympathy for the world and
couldn't believe they were
rejected and Ellen says she felt very
sad that this was the case because that
wasn't the present Truth at the time it
was the present truth that God had
rejected the Wicked
World meaning Ellen felt sad that this
woman had a burden for the
Lost God had rejected them and it was to
believe to be believed that their
opportunity for salvation was over so to
go against that was evil that's what God
had revealed Ellen felt sad about this
which is why she then goes on and
continues to say
this at length my soul seemed to be in
an Agony and while she was
talking I fell from my chair to the
floor it was
then I had a view of Jesus rising from
his mediatorial throne and going to the
holiest as bridegroom to receive his
kingdom they were all deeply interested
in The View
you they all said it was entirely new to
them the Lord worked in Mighty power
setting the truth home to their
hearts sister Durban knew what the power
of the Lord was for she had felt it many
times and a short time after I fell she
was struck down and fell to the floor
crying to God to have mercy on
her when I came out of vision my ears
were saluted with sister deran singing
and shouting with a loud
voice most of them receiv received the
vision and were settled upon the shut
door previous to this I had no light on
the coming of the bridegroom but had
expected him to come to this earth to
deliver his people on the 10th day of
the seventh month I did not hear a
lecture or a word in any way relating to
the bridegrooms going to the holiest
close
quote wow so remember in part one
Stephen talked of the investigative
judgment being the start of when Jesus
went to receive his kingdom and once
that work is finished the kingdom of God
will be complete it stems back to this
Vision
ultimately so sister Durban had a burden
for the lost this made Ellen sad because
sister Durban was out of line with what
the present truth was Ellen then
conveniently goes into Vision where she
saw Jesus rising from his mediatorial
throne and moving into the most holy
place to receive his kingdom and through
this
Vision sister Durban and others came to
accept the shut door because she knew
the power of God when she saw it and was
convinced that God really showed this to
Ellen White again this was
before it allegedly
became or or eventually sorry became
that when one door shut another opened
so salvation is actually still
possible this is precisely why that
became the new Theory because they had
to Pivot off of the original error that
the whole world was lost and there was
no more hope for
them and it was the another door opened
which involved the Sabbath and the Ten
Commandment truth along with the
investigative
judgment they didn't have the alleged
Sabbath truth in
1845 that became part of the new light
with the realization that one door
closed and another
opened
furthermore is this only the
ministers spiritual gifts volume 1 page
189 we've looked at this before quote I
saw that since Jesus had left the holy
place of the Heavenly sanctuary and
entered within the the second Veil the
churches were left as were the
Jews and they had been filling up with
every unclean and hateful bird I saw
great iniquity and vess in the churches
yet they profess to be Christians their
profession their prayers and their
exhortations are an abomination in the
sight of God close
quote this is in 1858 folks
even after the one door closed and
another one opened excuse the Christians
that rejected their silliness were seen
as apostates that God was angry with
they weren't true Christians for
rejecting the 1844 Doctrine and because
of that their prayers and exhortations
were an abomination in the sight of
God by this point they're not saying
that the opportunity for salvation is up
they've pivoted off of that you can
study the history around their kids
start getting older and there's a
correlation between that and the message
shifting but your salvation is in
Jeopardy after you hear the 1844 message
and reject it and that's where they're
still at
today folks we even see vestages of this
kind of of stuff back to William Miller
himself it wasn't identical to what the
little flock would go on to develop but
notice this is from a letter of
his quote we've done our work in warning
Sinners and in trying to awake a formal
church God in his Providence has shut
the door we can only stir one another up
to be patient and be diligent to make
our calling sure close
quote December 11
1844 couple months after the great
disappointment so here we see vestages
of this idea before the little flock and
Ellen's alleged First Vision which came
shortly after this also in December of
1844 and then that second Vision in
February Miller claimed they tried to
wake the church up to their false
prophecies and date setting but they
wouldn't listen rightfully so and so the
door was shut on them being ready for
Jesus's soon
return they weren't going to be ready
because they rejected Miller's message
you had people like Charles Fitch
preaching that if you don't believe in
premillennial eschatology you're lost
you're
damned you had to believe premillennial
imminent return of Christ
theology in like that aspect of of
Doctrine or you weren't going to be
ready you're going to get the wrath of
God poured out on you because you don't
believe in
premillennialism that's what we're
dealing with here folks this idea that
it was only the Ministers of the day
pathetic Uriah Smith is a
joke remember the SDA Church's mission
statement they're heralding this
message so that people can be prepared
for the soon return of
Jesus if you reject the SDA churches
present truth message you'll be lost
it's the exact same thing Miller is
saying here but presid Truth at that
time was
different you had to believe Miller's
message the formal church had gone
apostate
yeah and notice how SDA Pioneer JH
Wagner he even recognized this in
1883 about William Miller quote it's
easy to show that the construction put
upon the faith of the seventh day
Adventists on the subject of the shut
door is in entirely
wrong that the great body of Adventists
while uh with Mr Miller did for a short
time after the disappointment of
1844 believ that the whole world the
world had received its last warning is
true beyond all
doubt they could hardly think otherwise
with their faith on the Judgment message
close
quote that the great body of Adventists
the
millerites along with William Miller did
for a short time after the
disappointment of 1844 indeed believe
that the world had received its last
warning and it's true beyond all doubt
that that was the
case so Wagner was seeking to silence
claims regarding Adventist in the shut
door in his article but notice he says
that Miller did indeed believe this and
it's true beyond all
doubt after the disappointment of 1844
they believed the world received its
last warning not just Ministers of the
day now I've gone into the shut door in
even more detail elsewhere so you can go
check that out on our website and the
YouTube channel the point being the
Adventist understanding on the Three
Angels of Revelation is supposedly
coming from God It's the final message
from God to the Earth that the
Adventists allegedly have yet it
initially included the idea and the
belief that the door of Mercy was shut
only the little flock would be saved
they were the 144,000 that even evolved
it was still evolving up until the past
the turn of the century after Allen dies
we're going to be getting into that some
here in the
future but they were the 144,000 from
the first Vision that supposedly heard
the voice of Jesus like many Waters
which gave them the day and hour of his
return Ellen was shown this in Vision
supposedly so God's final message to the
world has had to go through all sorts of
proofreading phases all these trials and
errors to work out the Kinks and get it
just right which involved him endorsing
practices that his word forbids and then
utilizing them to try and communicate a
special message of Salvation that only
these individuals now have arbitrarily
starting in the 19th
century that's what we're dealing with
here and this uh undering is what
influences the reason this is so
important folks is because this
undergirding is what influences the
handling of the biblical text and it's
then read into all sorts of things that
are not in view like we saw with
Revelation
15 he ties all of this stuff to this
message this novel nonsense back in the
19 century he reads scripture in light
of that or rather the SDA Church does
because he's really just a mouthpiece of
sales for the
organization none of the biblical
writers had a great controversy
worldview they weren't even preaching
the 1844 message yet John the Apostle
apparently is referring to the most holy
place of a building opening for a second
time not to be entered by faith in the
SDA Sanctuary message but for the
plagues to be poured out on everyone
that rejects
it makes absolutely no sense if John
didn't have a great controversy
worldview so I hope you understand how
important this backdrop influences the
conclusions that they draw from the text
for their interpretation that's
supposedly
inspired this is simply the scripture
they point to to pigeon hole in their
novel teaching to then try and claim
it's biblical because oh I can point to
a verse yeah try that same thing with
Acts 20 ver7 oh no no no and then
they'll get into all sorts of details
and oh right so you don't just accept a
person just citing a verse
right rules for thee but not for for
me no ultimately this stuff comes from a
vision that solidifies it in then they
have to make the Bible find a way to say
this to validate having the spirit of
Prophecy because remember that's tied to
all of
this that's why she's an integral part
you can't do this alart style I'm a I'm
a real Adventist yeah says every
Adventist of the five million different
splintering groups out of
adventism no the stuff comes from
Visions from Ellen White that they have
to use the apocalyptic parts of
scripture and use symbolism to try and
trojan horse in the system under those
symbols so what is revelation 15 5-8
getting at let's actually read the whole
chapter it's only eight verses
here notice
then I saw another sign in
heaven great and amazing seven angels
with seven plagues which are the last
for uh with them the wrath of God is
finished and I saw what appeared to be a
sea of glass mingled with fire and also
those who had conquered the beast in its
image and the number of its name
standing beside the sea of glass with
harps of God in their hands and they
sing the song of Moses the servant of
God and the song of the lamb saying
great and amazing are your Deeds oh Lord
God the
almighty just and true are your ways oh
King of the
Nations who will not fear oh Lord and
glorify your name for you alone Are Holy
All Nations will come and worship you
for your righteous acts have been
revealed after this I looked and the
sanctuary of the tent of witness in
heaven was opened and out of the
sanctuary came the seven angels with the
seven plagues clothed in pure bright
linen with golden sashes around their
chests and one of the four living
creatures gave to the seven angels seven
golden Bulls full of the wrath of God
who lives forever and ever and the
sanctuary was filled with smoke from the
glory of God and from his power and no
one could enter the sanctuary until the
seven plagues of the Seven Angels were
finished and thus the reading of God's
holy
word so this chapter is obviously if you
study it is connected to chapter 14 of
which Steven bour in the SDA
interpretation recognize and agree it is
in that chapter chapter 14 that the
Judgment in focus is with regard to the
wicked not the
righteous if you read through the
entirety of chapter 14 it's all about
judgment on the
wicked Ellen White simply lumped in the
Christian church with the wicked because
she was a a false accuser of the
Brethren that if she didn't repent she
is being tormented right
now and this is what William Miller was
claiming he had that understanding
correct this is clearly about the wicked
he believed and was claiming that the
Earth would be judged with fire and the
wicked
punished then this teaching
pivots to supposedly being a judgment
distinctly for professing believers with
the investigative judgment supposedly in
view but no it's about the wicked and
it's also What flows in chapter
15 just like in chapter 14 pledges and
guarantees are given with regards to all
the enemies of the Christian church that
they would be stopped and the church
would be triumphant we talked about this
a little bit last week the overarching
theme of the book of Revelation is about
the church being triumphant because
Christ overcame the world and he is the
head of the
church he's writing this to give
encouragement to the seven churches in
Asia Minor which were about to undergo
severe
persecution so the chapter starts with
him seeing a new sign in
heaven seven angels that appear which
have seven plagues stored up for the
Wrath that would come upon the beast
power the ones that did have victory
over the Beast the church were seen
standing beside the sea of glass
rejoicing at the destruction of the
enemy which led to All Nations coming to
worship before the true God that's
verses two and four or 2 through
four he then
sees these seven angels coming out of a
temple with their plagues to be poured
out versus 5-8 one of the four
beasts that's Before the Throne gives
these angels seven golden vials of the
wrath of
God do you think these are literal
vials because the SDA Church tells us
you know a literal Temple was opened and
this physical temple building in heaven
is supposed to support the idea of 1844
well are these vials
literal no this is a
vision it's pictures to point to Greater
realities and points these angels then
pour them out upon the Earth bringing
the Beast to
destruction this leads to the temple
being filled with smoke keeping anyone
from
entering Now quickly here before moving
forward I want to play a small clip from
Dr GK
Beal who is notoriously known for his
work on Revelation over the decades
listen to what he points out regarding
the physical literality of reading
Revelation this way he's speaking on
Revelation 11 in this clip from his
Revelation series but catch what he says
regarding Revelation reference to the
temple in
heaven and one of the things we find
first of all in our passage notice verse
one that was given me a measuring Rod
like a staff someone said rise and
measure the temple of God and the Altar
and those who Worship in it and so
immediately the question is is this a
physical Temple many who were genuine
Bible Believers and Bible believing
Scholars think it is others think it is
a spiritual
Temple well we're going to let scripture
Define these things for us and this is
part uh using this as a test case how
does Scripture help us here well one of
the best things you can have is a
concordance if you don't have a
concordance go buy one you can probably
get one in the bookstore here if you had
to go to an island and only had two
books to take Bible and
concordance uh concordance is very
important you can look up words and
phrases see how they're used elsewhere
in this case the phrase look at that
phrase here the um temple of God right
there that phrase occurs 10 other times
in the New Testament and guess
what not one time does it refer to a
building or an architectural building
not one time for example you probably
remember 1 Corinthians 3:16 uh uh do you
not know that you're a temple of God
verse 17 uh if anyone destroys the
temple of God God will destroy him and
in part of that verse for um the temple
of God is Holy 2 Corinthians
6:16 uh and what agreement has the
temple of God with Idols for we are the
temple of God and I could go on now
there may be one place where
temple of God is literal and it's in
Matthew chap 26 and uh verse um 61 I'm
going to read that for you verse
61 it's at Jesus trial and there's a
false witness here's what the false
witness uh about what Jesus says and
this man stated the false witness said
that Jesus said I'm able to destroy the
temple of God and rebuild it in 3 days
he obviously had a literal
interpretation saying oh that's
impossible the real version of this
passage occurs in John 2 where Jesus is
speaking with the religious leaders and
he says tear down this Temple and I will
rebuild it in three days and then it
goes on to say but he was speaking of
the Temple of his body and so he sees
that he's begun to be the temple in his
ministry that's why he says don't don't
go and uh uh perform the sacrifices
anymore I am going to sacrifice
forgiveness revolves around me if you
want forgiveness it revolves around me
he begins to be the temple and then when
they kill him you can't keep a good
Temple man down he rises right back up
in Resurrection and so um uh even there
in Matthew 26 therefore this is not a
depiction of a literal Temple it is I
think if we're going to let scripture
interpret scripture it is the church it
is the people of God Christians are part
of the true
Temple why because Christ was the
beginning of that Temple and when we
come into Union with him we being
identified with him begin to be part of
that
Temple all right so for the Adventists
in the audience
Dr Beal just put forth one of William
Miller's rules of Bible
interpretation which the SDA Church
claims to still
uphold just the Bible in a
concordance and if you utilize that
principle with the phrase found in
Revelation 11 that refers to the temple
in heaven you see it's never used to
refer to a literal architectural
building but I wanted to listen to this
for people to hear that this isn't as
watered down and simple the SDA Church
likes to portray making it seem like
they've mastered something that no one
else has because they supposedly have an
infallible interpreter of scripture that
only contradicts the the scriptures at
every turn yeah nice try but no but the
SDA position has to have this literal
building because as we heard from Step
bour they connect the smoke filling the
temple with the SDA teaching regarding
the close of
probation no one will be able to enter
the Most Holy place by faith and follow
Jesus in the sanctuary aka the
opportunity to believe the 1844 message
which isn't just the investigative
judgment it's their whole novel system
of
theology the opportunity to believe that
will be up salvation will no longer be
possible again Mr bore John and his
audience did not have a great
controversy
worldview and it's from this worldview
that your guys is in entire theory
around the seven steps through the
sanctuary
comes that couldn't possibly be what
John intended to
communicate which means the text has to
arbitrarily take on some new secret
meaning at the point of receiving the
great controversy worldview in the 19th
century No it's word association fallacy
to read into the words judgment and
Sanctuary the SDA Theory which was the
result of false prophecies and claiming
God showed the the door of Mercy was
already shut which means probation was
believed to be closed at that
time saying that it's claiming once
probation closes and no one can enter
the sanctuary by faith followed up by
rhetorically asking can we really enter
the most holy place by
faith so he can he he includes
professing Believers in this that once
probation closes professing Believers
won't be able to approach
God but no this is the problem John is
writing encouragement to the church
despite the persecution it was about to
undergo the bowls are are poured out on
Wicked people and the closing off has to
do with the wicked not being able to
approach God not his people whom he's
Avenged through the destruction of the
church's
enemies this is describing the tri
ulation
judgments of which they're again this is
not as watered down as they like to
claim you know this silly notion that
they have bullet proof esoy and everyone
else is confused it's just the most
laughable claim ever like no dude all
the positions I don't care which one you
hold to they all have problems because
theology is complex it's vast it has
many moving parts and nuances it's like
only novices that step into the
room just I get Adventists all the time
that claim I think I'm a know- it all my
the
irony the you claim to have the
theological God Particle The Theory of
Everything not even close
dude I don't even talk about so many
theological aspects on this platform
that because we're getting into like you
just have to be a theology nerd to even
get in at that level I don't know
anything when it comes to that I'm here
just sharing information from trying to
get people caught up to
speed but this is describing the
tribulation judgments of which there are
arguments as to when this uh you know
occurs or
occurred and that while those are being
poured out one can't approach God and
this is actually a play off of what we
see in Exodus which we talked about this
in and passing in the intro in part
one God coming in a
cloud both when the temple was
consecrated in Exodus 40 which is what I
cited with Moses and and in First Kings
8 with Solomon's Temple both were filled
with
smoke when the high priest would enter
the holy of holies they took smoking
incense with them which overshadowed the
imagery in the temple that's what's
being alluded to here it's not saying
literally in heaven there's an arc of
the Covenant and and a
Laver and a curtain and a building and a
bunch of apartments no dude it's
teaching you about greater reality
this again serves as a picture like we
looked at in part one regarding Jesus
the cloud riter entering into heaven as
the great high priest to be inaugurated
as a king and take his throne begin
ruling and reigning to conquer all of
his enemies part of which includes the
pouring out of these vials and bold
judgments not the end of you proclaiming
your novel message in that started in
1844 and when this corresponds with
that's not happening anymore probations
closing and smoke filling the temple is
going to represent this no the problem
with the SDA theory is one the timeline
and two inserting into the words
sanctuary and judgment their novel
definitions of both which ultimately
come from the great controversy
worldview and not the Bible as we've
looked at numerous times so they can
flaunt all they want that they have some
impeccable interpretation that's
theologically bulletproof all they want
where they literally just make a bunch
of assertions about the text and don't
even do any rigorous ex Jesus but just
know that Ellen White claimed to be
shown by God that probation had already
closed because the door of Mercy was
allegedly shut and then they had to
Pivot to what Steven bore put forth that
a new door actually opened so
probation's not actually closed which
means once again Ellen White was a false
prophet which scripture tells us to not
even listen to or entertain on top of
that Revelation 15 isn't talking about
God's people having to stand without a
mediator during the time of trouble but
then after the bowls are done they will
be able to approach God again at the
second coming when Michael the Archangel
stands up to rescue them which is what
he's going to now proceed to claim
listen very closely go to Daniel chapter
12 Daniel chter 12 and I want to read
verse 1 Daniel chap 12 and verse 1 it
says at that time incidentally let me
give you a little bit of context before
I finish reading this uh if you read the
previous verses it talks about the King
of the North the King of the North
represents the papacy it's the same
thing as the little horn the Beast the
man of sin the Harlot the abomination of
desolation you know uh the
Antichrist all are names of this system
different names given in different
contexts and so it says there in the
previous verses Daniel 114 44 and 45
that the King of the North will go out
with the intention of destroying and
slaying God's people it's the same as
Revelation 13 where it says that a death
decree is given against God's people
people will not be able to buy or sell
and those who do not worship the image
of the Beast will be what will be killed
so those two texts are uh to be studied
together so it says here at that time
when the King of the North goes out to
destroy God's people Michael shall stand
up now the question is what does that
mean Michael shall stand
up well we need to go to Daniel 11 and
verses 2 and 3 where the identical
expression is used Daniel 11 and veres 2
and three it says there and now I will
tell you the truth behold three more
Kings will arise in Persia now
unfortunately the translation doesn't
reflect the fact that it's the same word
in other words the word arise that is
used here in Daniel 11:2 is the same
identical word stand up that is used in
Daniel 12 and verse one so what does
this mean when it says three more Kings
will arise in Persia it means that three
more kings are going to rule in Persia
right three more kings are going to
reign in Persia now let's continue
reading and the fourth shall be far
richer than them all by his strength
through his his riches he shall stir up
all against the realm of Greece then a
mighty king shall arise there's the same
expression a mighty king shall stand up
what does that mean it means he's going
to begin to what he's going to begin to
rule or to Reign and it that's what it
says who shall rule with great dominion
and do according to his will so the
question is what does it mean that
Michael will stand up Michael is whom
Jesus Christ who is like God is the name
of the word of the name Michael so what
does it mean for Michael to stand up it
means that Jesus is going to begin to
what he's going to begin to Reign or
rule why because probation is just
closed and his kingdom is what his
kingdom is made up are you following me
or not his kingdom is made up because
the Judgment has finished now he's going
to stand up which means he's going to be
begin to rule over his kingdom which has
been established during the
investigative
judgment
wow
wow like what a take now we're going to
be doing a a deep dive on the SDA
teaching on Michael the Archangel in a
couple weeks so I will save some of this
until then but with regards to Daniel
121 Michael shall arise he pointed to
Daniel 112 through3 to say it talks
about a king arising which is pointing
to Jesus and he said when this happens
is when Jesus what
he will begin to
rule Mr Bor this is completely
backwards that's why I face
paled this is the subtle spin that SDA
theology does folks it is very close to
the
truth but subtly twists to fit with the
great controversy
worldview Kings do not begin to re sir
when they stand
up they Reign from on their
Throne again the text does not say that
when this King arises it means he will
begin to Reign he's already on the
throne which means he's already reigning
at that
point and if you watched part one folks
we looked at this and why understanding
that Daniel 7 is referring to the
Ascension is so
important notice where bore is getting
this from
I was speaking about the word to the
little flock Vision
earlier
quote you think that those who worship
before the Saints feet in Revelation 3:9
will at last be saved here I must differ
with you for God sh me that this class
were professed Adventists who had fallen
away and crucified to themselves the Son
of God aresh and put him to an open
shame came and in the hour of Temptation
which is yet to come it's talking about
the time of
trouble to show out everyone's true
character they will know that they are
forever lost and overwhelmed with
anguish of spirit they will bow at the
Saints feet you also think that Michael
stood up and the time of trouble
commenced in the spring of
1844 the Lord has shown me in vision
that Jesus rose up and shut the door and
entered the holy of holies at the
seventh month
1844 but Michael standing up Daniel 121
to deliver his people is in the
future this will not take place until
Jesus has finished his Priestly office
in the Heavenly sanctuary and lays off
his Priestly attire and puts on his most
kingly robes and Crown to ride forth on
the Cloudy Chariot to thresh the he the
Heathen in anger and deliver his people
close
quote this is what Steven is putting
forth Ellen said it was supposedly shown
this in Vision therefore it has to be
true and the text has to be molded to
fit with
this I've talked about this before but
remember in part one we looked at a
statement from SDA Professor Roy gain he
is a proponent that what alen white saw
in Vision regarding the temple in heaven
was symbolic to represent certain
realities we saw where he claimed that
there isn't a literal curtain in the
Heavenly Sanctuary that Jesus entered
behind in 1844 that was representative
of His function and Ministry it
represented him changing from a priest
to a
king or or sorry the changing of the
garments did his moving from one
apartment to the other well it's not
necessarily a literal Veil it was just a
representation of him changing
Ministry but that's what's going on here
the changing of the garments Jesus Will
transition from being a priest when he
changes out of the levitical priesthood
garments that Ellen White saw him
wearing and he puts on kingly garments
it is not a simultaneous role in their
system now let's look at Hebrews 7 which
showcases the SDA church can claim all
the they want that they teach Jesus is
after the order of melkisedek and not
the Levites but this is one of the many
evidences they do not understand what
this
means Hebrews 6:19 through 7 1-3 we'll
be getting into more of this later
but we have this as a sure and steadfast
anchor of the Soul a hope that enters
into the inner place behind the curtain
where Jesus has gone as a forerunner on
our behalf having become a high priest
forever Burr after the order of
melchisedek for this melchisedec king of
Salem priest of the most high God met
Abraham returning from the slaughter of
the Kings and blessed him and to him
Abraham apportioned a tenth part of
everything he is first by translation of
his name king of
righteousness and then he is also king
of Salem that is king of Peace he is
without father or mother or genealogy
having neither beginning of days nor end
of life but resembling the Son of God he
continues a
priest
forever thus the reading of God's holy
word so we're going to read a good
portion of Hebrews 7 after a bit more
but notice Jesus is a high priest for
how long after the order of
melchisedek
forever and melchisedek was king of
Salem
re e of the most high God melchisedec
was
simultaneously a priest and
King he wasn't a priest and then took
those garments off and put on different
garments and became a king at a later
point
no he was a type and Shadow that pointed
to Jesus and the whole point of him
talking about Abraham giving tithes to
maladec he explains that the when the
giving of the tithe shows a a superior
superiority uh inferiority superiority
exchange taking place and he's
explaining how Jesus can be even better
than Abraham because Abraham gave a
tithe to melchisedek who blessed Abraham
and Jesus is after the order of mesc
showing how Jesus is even better than
Abraham that's what's going on
here but in this exchange he explains
how melchisedec was both a king and a
priest simultan
ously so Jesus is both a high priest and
King
simultaneously he is the true king of
peace and righteousness and he will
forever be such holding his office Sim
that simultaneous office
forever
and the fact that Jesus is seated
indicates he's not dealing with sin
remember the daily work of the priests
was a standing work every priest stood
daily the author tells us in chapter 9
remember back to Ellen's Vision we
followed him in the most holy place
where I saw him
standing what no the author of Hebrews
goes to Great Lengths Ellen to explain
that Jesus is seated in stark contrast
to the standing work showing his
accomplishment of his wants unlike them
he was able to offer
one time enter into the presence of God
sit
down compared to this long drawn out
thing that came through the law that
wasn't able to perfect
people it's like a stark contrast nope
he's he's standing in there you know
she's just on VIP tour you know she's
she she's got Jesus on speed dial you
know she's the last human being that
talked to
Jesus think about it
after his Ascension what human being
talked to Jesus well the apostles got
some of them John for example in the
apocalypse but then fast forward to the
19th century This Woman's getting
Heavenly
tourism she's having flowery
conversations with yeah
okay but Steven and the SDA church has
Jesus standing to end the work of
dealing with sin
he's still dealing with sin seated doing
the investigative judgment which is
backwards Ellen says he's standing but
then you'll talk to him they'll like no
no we believe he's Seated on the throne
Daniel 7 he he approached the the the
father and and sat down to begin the
books of judgment were
opened and like she said in the vision
he walked in and she has him standing
and seated and well
yeah but notice what he told us when he
stands he'll end the work of dealing
with sin probation
closes so he's dealing with it seated
doing the investigative judgment which
is backwards and when they have him
ending the work of dealing with sin is
when he
stands it's just like every turn
Folks at a certain point I just when we
get inundated with testimonies I'm just
like I'm glad it's clicking for some of
y'all you're seeing it just every step
of the way is backwards backwards
backwards everything's backwards back to
sin back to the old Covenant back back
back back to the Levites back to
everything's back back to Eden just so
sick of looking backwards man are you
sick of looking backwards Adventist it's
like come be a Christian where we're
looking forward the actual kingdom of
God
like get out of this group get out of
this this group I understand you like
the people I understand I'm not saying
have to shun the people I'm not saying
hate the people but get the heck out of
this get out of this just silliness it
everything's
backwards now you're going to have an
Adventist Point here to claim that this
was Jesus that this part of
scripture specifically Hebrews 6:1 19
and 20 that are going to point here to
claim this proves Jesus was inaugurated
to be a priest at his Ascension because
it talks of Jesus entering into the holy
place at his Ascension like we saw in
part
one but they will say it says having
become a high priest which they take to
mean the author is saying at the point
of entering Heaven he became a high
priest they take it as like a Time
marker that's how they're reading it but
no the author already told us back in
Chapter 2 that Jesus functioned as a
priest in the giving up of himself at
Calvary which is exactly in accordance
with the Old Testament the high priest
alone had to offer up the day of
atonement sacrifice which the SDA Church
claims the cross of Calvary was the day
of atonement
sacrifice but no the author is not
saying that this is when Jesus became a
high
priest having become is not said with
regard to at that point in time it's not
a Time
marker it's saying that since he is a
high priest Forever After the order of
mchis
we have as an anchor for our
souls the the point being Jesus is a
high priest and king forever
simultaneously it's tied to his Rule and
Reign which not just Hebrews but
Revelation Daniel 7 say will be forever
and ever into eternity which we're going
to see again in full a little bit
later but Mr bour also said this
standing in Daniel is proof that Jesus
is beginning to Reign because his
kingdom is made up after the
investigative judgment this is the
second time that he said this he said
this last time too yes except
Stephen as we looked at last time this
happens by Jesus ruling and reigning
with all authority in heaven and on
Earth Jesus isn't sitting by helping
people get to a point where they're
totally sinless vindicating the
character of God silencing Satan then he
can stand up because his Kingdom's
complete that's what the SDA system is
essentially
positing versus what the Bible puts
forth which is that the kingdom of God
is ushered in into its fullness because
it's already here with Jesus already
ruling and
reigning and it's
because because he is ruling and
reigning that all of his enemies are
made a foot stol and that his kingdom
comes to its
fullness you catch the difference
he'll begin reigning once the kingdom is
completed no the kingdom comes about and
and is completed will be completed
because he's ruling and reigning right
now and will bring it to its fullest
fruition this is another case of the SDA
framework having the cart before the
horse he will rule and Reign after his
kingdom is complete versus the Bible
teaching that he rules and Reigns which
ultimately brings about the fullness of
the Kingdom
so does probation
close before Jesus comes let's finish
reading Daniel 12 verse one at that time
Michael shall stand up that's he begin
to rule because his kingdom is complete
the great prince who stands watch over
the sons of your people and now listen
carefully and there shall be a time of
trouble does this come after he stands
up after he begins to rule yes and there
shall be a time of trouble such as never
was since there was a nation so is there
going to be a time of trouble after
probation closes and before Jesus comes
yes it continues saying there shall be a
time of trouble such as never was since
there was a nation even to that time and
then comes the deliverance and and at
that time your people shall be what
delivered that's the coming of Jesus
shall be delivered everyone who is found
written in the book why are they written
in the book
because they were judged and they were
accounted worthy to be in the book in
the Judgment that was done previously
are you with me or not all of this fits
together and it makes
sense yeah it all fits together which is
why if one piece of this thing Falls the
whole house of cards collapses and as
has been
shown numerous points of this Theory
collapse we will save the claims about
Michael for a couple weeks from now like
I said but I want you to notice
Christian that he said the investigative
judgment is about God determining who is
and isn't
worthy I've talked about this numerous
times but it Bears
repeating salvation is not for people
found worthy
folks they can spin it whatever I've
heard all the excuses I'm telling
you
no Stephen is saying this because again
Ellen White talked of Salvation as a
reward for your perfect obedience to the
law
notice
quote the work of the investigative
judgment and the blotting out of sins is
to be accomplished before the second
Advent of the
Lord since the dead are to be judged out
of the things written in the books it is
impossible that the sins of men should
be blotted out until after the Judgment
at which their cases are to be
investigated but the the Apostle Peter
distinctly states that the sins of
Believers will be blotted out when the
times of refreshing shall come from the
presence of the Lord and He Shall send
Jesus Christ acts 3:19 and 20 when the
investigative judgment closes Christ
will come and his reward will be with
him to give to every man as his work
shall be close
quote now in part one we looked at how
the rewards in the verse of of
revelation 22 that they point to for
this isn't in reference to Salvation
being the
reward is just assumed that this is
talking about well the reward he returns
with is is for people's
salvation and this is where the slip
happens because the the text does in
indeed say that Christ is returning with
his
reward but it doesn't say it's salvation
for those to insert
whatever it's the same rewards talked
about regarding work done for the
kingdom in the gospels it's like not
every mention in scripture this is the
problem too with the system and we saw
this a couple weeks ago I mentioned the
kingdom of God back when we were talking
about the Eucharist and an Adventist
commented on there and said when you
used the term leaven to refer to the
kingdom did you mean sin because when
they talk about the supper they
associate leaven with sin because one
place in scripture leev is associated
with sin it now universally always
applies to
sin and I said no I was referring to
Matthew 13 where Jesus literally says
the kingdom of God is like a lump of
dough that a woman is needing and puts
yeast leaven in and it slowly Rises
which is what I reiterated in the the
the
video but the point being is that words
don't you have to understand the way
words are being used in the context in
which they're used it's not just this
Universal import but that's what they do
in this system it's like anytime rewards
are mentioned it has to be for salvation
right something about the reward is is
ET is
salvation sometimes it's saying that
sometimes it's not saying that it's
talking about something
else but in the context that we looked
at last time in part one it's not about
salvation it's the rewards that one will
receive for their work to further the
kingdom that's why we do this ministry
by the way that's why this platform
ultimately exists in the big picture
it's not for a bunch of clicks
whatever in signs of the times July 31st
notice for the highest good of his
creatures God has given a perfect law a
law that demands perfect
obedience that is correct the law
demands perfect obedience never violated
it a single
time God compels no one to obey his
law he leaves men free to decide whether
they will obey and receive the reward of
obedience or disobey and receive the
punishment of
transgression yeah that's where the
that's where the slip comes
in
because God's law does require perfect
obedience but you're screwed you've
broken the law and then they try to
insert in that Jesus gives you a a
number of doovers to keep trying until
you get to a point where now you're no
longer violating it okay now you're
fit no dude no you need Jesus's perfect
righteousness in full not little
spurts where oh I we get it imputed in
in justification but then over time the
you know sanctification is is tied to
that like that and you get uh Jesus's
merits gradually imparted to you getting
you ultimately to where you have to get
if you want to be saved and you know
they'll use phrases like Dennis prie
does of meeting the conditions no this
is all just a bunch of
twisting when you don't actually
understand what the standard actually is
or you do rather but then you have a
false understanding of how you can how
you can meet that
standard but again in mind character and
personality
quote he talking about Jesus came to
demonstrate the fact that Humanity
Allied by Living Faith to Divinity can
keep all the Commandments of God he came
to make plain the immutable character of
the law to declare that Disobedience and
transgression can never be rewarded with
eternal life he came as a man to to
humanity that Humanity might touch
Humanity while Divinity laid hold upon
the throne of God close
quote yeah then the SDA church is in a
lot of trouble because they violate the
first four of the Ten Commandments by
having a false god and they violate the
other six by preaching a false gospel
which isn't love for God or neighbor but
actually is the equivalent of spiritual
murder of one's
neighbor but obedience in their system
is not simply the fruit of already
having eternal
life it's what one does which will then
be rewarded with eternal
life again it's a slight twisting of the
truth by misplacing the role that
obedience
plays and when you take umage with this
Adventists will be quick to say that
you're advocating for
Disobedience when no nothing could be
further from the truth I know no
Christian I don't care what tradition
they're a part of I don't know a sing
Christian that thinks that it's just
such a silly thing to
think yeah there's probably oneoff
individuals out there somewhere that you
can point to but no official Christian
document of any sort because no one
believes that because that's not what's
being said that's not the
problem I'm advocating for not
misplacing obedience and putting the
cart yet again before the horse which
makes salvation something that's earned
because that's what a reward is it's
something that someone receives for
their efforts and
achievements but the New Testament is
clear salvation is a gift eternal life
is a gift not a
reward again in 1909 6 years before her
death Ellen White in the review and
Herald we see the world working to the
point of establishing by law a full
Sabbath and making it a test for
all this question will soon be before us
oh yeah here we are but it's coming next
year guys it'll be here next
year it's coming it's coming just keep
holding on trust the plan guys trust the
present truth plan yeah this is
1909 100 years you know but it's coming
it it it's coming
this question will soon be before us
God's Sabbath will be Trampled Under
Foot and a false Sabbath will be
exalted in a Sunday law there is
possibility for great suffering to those
who observe the seventh day the working
out of Satan's plan will bring
persecution to the people of God but the
Faithful Servants of God need not fear
the outcome of the conflict if they will
follow the pattern set for them in the
Life of Christ
if they will be true to the requirements
of God their reward will be eternal life
a life that measures with the life of
God close quote no
wrong obedience flows from possessing
eternal life because those that don't
possess eternal life don't have a desire
to obey God
this is why their false
anthropology is so
dangerous it distorts so many
things those that don't possess eternal
life have don't have a desire to obey
God they want nothing to do with God
that's what the Bible teaches doesn't
teach this sort of like neutral ground
and angel and devil on the shoulder and
you're just being pulled in two
directions no you are born
default fallen in atom hater of
God that's what you naturally desire it
doesn't take somebody causing you to be
that
way they want nothing to do with
God one doesn't seek to follow God and
then because of their obedience and
doing so they receive eternal life as a
reward yet this movement will try and
tell you no no no we don't teach Works
righteousness we don't teach people are
saved by their obedience we don't teach
a person's Works have any Merit
right you just teach that people will
receive eternal life by their perfect
obedience to the Ten Commandments that's
meeting the
conditions something none of them
actually uphold because their view of
sin is far too truncated and they don't
understand how deep it runs and how
offensive it is to God if they did
they'd understand why Christians are not
pelagians and don't believe in sinless
perfectionism until God glorifies the
bodies now there's going to be some
Traditions like Rome they claim an act
of purification has to happen after
death for most people
Purgatory a a purging of basically just
a finishing work of
sanctification which who knows how long
it could be they've argued over that for
a long time some say it's instantaneous
some say it's it could be a long length
of time I don't think they even have an
official teaching on
that the length of time but they then
claim that brings about glorification
believing that no it's an instantaneous
thing that's essentially what the
classical Protestants would
say but all parties recognize that you
will be imperfect this side of the Grave
because they understand the nature of
man but not the Seventh
Adventist there are supposedly countless
ones that have short circuited the
process of Salvation and have already
arrived at the glorified State they no
longer fall short of the glory of God
which Roman says that's part of what sin
is for all have sinned and fall short of
the glory of
God they claiming that probation is
granted to you giving you a window to
get busy and get going on your
sanctification as a co-laborer with
Christ and this will lead to you
eventually getting to a totally sinless
state where you have an identical
character to Jesus locked in before the
close of
probation because that's the character
that you're going have for eternity we
saw that in part
one so know that they will deny it and
play semantic games but yes this
movement's official system teaches a
Works righteousness model of Salvation
which sounds Noble and Pious on the
surface but it is actually a distortion
of the Gospel of Jesus Christ and they
have no business pointing the finger at
other people like Ro typically Roman
Catholics to say they believe in Works
salvation yeah okay okay there's another
story in the Bible that shows that
probation will
close and there will be a period of time
between the close of Probation and the
coming of Jesus I'm referring to what
happened in the days of Noah Noah
preached a powerful message didn't he
for 120 years could we say that the book
was opened so to speak during those 120
years was a message shared could people
be saved most certainly but then what
happened no notice Genesis 7:16 when
Noah finishes his preaching something
happens Genesis 7:16 says so those that
entered male and female talking about
the animals of All Flesh went in as God
had commanded him and the Lord shut him
in so was the door shut yeah who shut
the door the Lord the Lord shut the door
so as soon as the door was closed it's
started to
rain nope how long went by between when
the door closed and it started to rain
when the destruction came seven days do
you think that during that period the
faith of Noah and his family was
severely
tested how do you think that the people
outside behaved for each day that went
by they became more and more violent and
more and more daring was there a time of
trouble so to speak for no and his
family inside the ark was it a day of
victory for the wicked who were outside
yes it
was all right so now you're getting a
glimpse into how their hermeneutic
Christian reads everything in the Bible
in light of
eschatology what can Cain and aable
teach us about eschatology what can
Noah's Arc teach us about eschatology
what can Elijah in First Kings 18 teach
us about eschatology those of you that
have been riding with us for a while you
know why I'm referring to those specific
ones cuz
those are the ones that we've looked at
what can Adam and Eve teach us about
esoy everything is read through the
light of esoy which means they have to
make some sort of typology Leviticus 16
out of everything in the Bible it is
their typology is their favorite thing
because they can just try and make all
these parallels like we just
saw but this is a very common appeal
that they make to try and support both
present truth as well as what as well as
to support the claim that what they
preach is the same gospel that's always
been preached it's not different he said
Noah preached a powerful message didn't
he could we say that the book was opened
so to speak during those 120 years was a
message shared could people be saved
notice he said a message not the message
a
message and out of this they try and
then claim that what Noah preached was
to get on the ark and they'd be
saved but that's not what people are to
preach
today there's not a flood coming there's
no we're not calling people to get on
the
ark but there's a message that is the
present Truth for this time and it's
what the SDA church has because what
Noah had that was a present truth
message for his
time they utilize this argument all the
time Jonah is another one they love to
point to in the same vein so be prepared
to hear that but Mr boore the issue when
you guys do this is that one didn't
receive the Forgiveness of sins if they
hypothetically listened to
Noah Noah's sins were not forgiven
because he built a boat the gospel for
Noah was not if you build a boat your
sins will be
forgiven Noah was already walking with
God before even receiving the command to
build the ark Genesis
69 so so pointing to the fact that he
preached a message that was for a
distinct time to try and make the gospel
also something that is unique depending
on the time period is comparing apples
and
oranges it's also an example of trying
to take a type and Shadow and prove too
much and in doing so it creates blunders
notice what Steven is reiterating though
review and Herald November 29 1934 page
quote this movement with which we are
connected stands for certain great
fundamental truths the existence of God
the inspiration of the Holy scriptures
salvation alone through the vicarious
sacrifice of the Lord Jesus repentance
regeneration and the gift of
righteousness by faith the work of the
Holy Spirit the immutability of God's
law The Binding claims of the Bible
Sabbath the Priestly Ministry of Christ
in the Heavenly sanctuary
the investigative judgment now going on
the soon coming of Christ to take his
children home the doctrine of the
spiritual gifts the manifestation of the
gift of Prophecy in the remnant Church
Life only in Christ Christian Temperance
and other leading important Bible
doctrines these great
truths constitute the Everlasting gospel
message for this
time close
quote so Noah had the message of get on
to the ark the sdas have all these
doctrines listed and that's what
supposedly constitutes the Everlasting
gospel for this
time their system of theology is what is
the fullness of the truth and must be
believed to be
saved Noah had a message they have a
message and that's supposed to prove the
gospel message itself fluctuates
depending on when in history you're
referring but it's the same message it's
the same message
though more SDA double speak which is
why they continue by saying in the next
paragraph to the Seventh Adventist
Church has been committed this
message the Everlasting gospel was
preached by Noah by Abraham by Paul and
Peter and by all the prophets and
apostles of past ages it was preached in
the setting appropriate to their day
we cannot preach the gospel message as
Noah preached it or as Paul or Luther
gave
it it is for us to
preach in the setting of God's Great
three-fold message of Revelation
14 Luther preached righteousness by
faith in the setting of The Gospel
message for the 16th century we must
preach righteousness by faith in the
setting of God's message for this
time we are told by the messenger of the
Lord Ellen White quote several have
written to me inquiring if the message
of justification by faith is the third
Angel's message and I have answered it
is the third Angel's message in Verity
review and Herald April 1st
1890 the Apostle Paul preached of
righteousness and Temperance and of a
judgment to
come we cannot preach the Judgment of
God as did the apostle
we must preach the hour of his judgment
is come that judgment is now going
forward the investigative judgment the
great underlying principles of these
truths are the
same but in our preaching their
application must be made to present day
conditions close
quote just dripping in classic SDA
double speake
the great underlaying principles are the
same and it's the same Everlasting
gospel but it can't be preached as the
apostles because it's a message
distinctly for this time entrusted
exclusively to the SDA
church but it's the same message
fundamentally nope nice try this is just
a verbose way of saying you have a false
gospel that the apostles did not preach
notice they try and say the apostles
preached about a judgment to come and so
do we referring to the investigative
judgment and that's supposed to mean
they preach the same thing as the
apostles no it doesn't work that way
like whoa it does not work that way at
all what in the
world the appeal to Noah is a category
error Noah wasn't forgiven of his sins
because he built an ark the message that
brings the Forgiveness of sins is the
gospel not getting on an ark the gospel
isn't a message it's a distinctive
message a fixed message that doesn't
change and in fact we don't have a ton
of stuff about Noah like this because
that's not what you're supposed to be
deducing out of Noah a bunch of
eschatological nonsense where you just
read yourself into the story where we
represent Noah
and
no no you're just trying to use typology
and this is the problem with typo I mean
I I I like typology but man this is why
so many theologians warn about typology
because you can just make all sorts of
crazy inferences when you do this but
then he appealed to Genesis
7:16 God shut the door of the Ark and it
began to rain and this is a picture of
probation closing and vindicates the SDA
teaching
apparently people had an opportunity for
120 years they didn't listen the door
was shut and the wrath of God was poured
out on all those that didn't enter the
ark except Stephen you failed to show us
the key component in your guys a
system where in the story of Noah did
you see that probation was allotted for
people to get to a totally sinless
condition and demonstrate that they're
worthy of Christ and his atoning
benefits and are fit for his
kingdom that's what you said this
investigative judgment is
about where is that in the story of
Noah oh no no that's part of that
present truth but it's the same message
but it's the same
message advinus this movement is trying
to scramble your
brain and where is the story of Noah say
that obedience to the Ten Commandments
is what would yield this
oh right right present
truth oh
convenient the command that Noah and his
family obeyed was about building the ark
and entering
it you guys agree that the Ten
Commandments transcend
SI I'm getting all the Evangelical
arrows shot at me right
now so where are they here as the
Baseline for all of those that heard
Noah to obey them get to a totally
sinless condition then they'd be
rewarded with entering the ark and being
saved because that's what you guys are
teaching specifically not just this
general idea of see well they had an
opportunity and the opportunity ended
therefore that justifies the SDA
teaching on
probation no doesn't work that way nice
try they love doing this though folks
they love boiling down the teaching to a
generic General concept and then find
something like this they think supports
it to Hitch the entirety of the teaching
to like boiling down probation as simply
the idea that right now salvation's
possible and eventually it won't
be no that's not all that you guys
claim whoa whoa whoa nice try but they
love doing this we saw this with Jud
Lake we've looked at other Scholars that
do this no not going to work just to
remind you we looked at this in part one
and I mentioned it
earlier quote we are not to settle down
expecting that a change of character
will come to us by some miraculous work
when Jesus shall appear in the Clouds Of
Heaven with power and great Glory know
my young friends we are judgment bound
and probation is granted to us here in
this
life in order that we may form
characters for the future Immortal
Life close
quote where is this in
Noah it
isn't so they'll conveniently say well
that's it's present Truth for probation
in our context and time
period yeah except the investigative
judgment supposedly entails all of the
people back to Adam who have professed
Faith none of them had a great
controversy
worldview just such a joke to try and
make some sort of con ction
here but this also shows that Christian
if an Adventist tries to use the show me
one verse argument which they love using
where some they act like something has
to be verbatim stated typically only on
the Sabbath remind them of this appeal
by the SDA Church to Noah to try and
infer that there was a time of trouble
for seven days and Noah and his family
in the ark experienced it Etc which is
supposed to then justify their novel
system give me a break dude the point
being appealing to Noah like they do is
a major stretch that ends up seeking to
prove too much because the parallels
aren't one to
one they're notorious for doing this the
entire investigative judgment is a
result of that same
thing Noah is a type and picture for us
yes but the type and Shadow is often not
exhaustive and is simply a picture
trying to point to that to to then
trojan horse in the entirety of your
novel
teaching uh yeah talk about abusing the
biblical
text Jesus referred to this in Matthew
24 and: 37-39 go with me to Matthew 24:
37-39 but as the days of Noah were so
also will the coming of the son of man
be do you see the two events that are
going that are being compared as it was
in the days of Noah so will it be at the
coming of the son of man for as in the
days before the flood
they were eating and drinking marrying
and giving in marriage now comes the
first until until the day that Noah
entered the Ark so the first until marks
the moment when Noah entered the Ark and
the door was what and the door was
closed but now notice and they did not
know who didn't know the people outside
what didn't they
know that they were lost that's right
and they did not know until the flood
came and took them all away so also will
the coming of the son of man be so is
the door of probation going to close
before Jesus comes is there going to be
a time time of trouble in between where
the faith of God's people will be tested
and the wicked will become more and more
daring against God's people absolutely
because Jesus says As it was back then
it will be at the End of Time
incidentally Jesus spoke of his coming
like the coming of a thief and and
people say oh the second coming is going
to be like like the coming of a thief uh
not
exactly not the way that we generally
think of it anyway I want you to imagine
you know it's one of those cold nights
in Fresno there's not very many of them
but it's in December and it's in it's
30° and you've come back from work and
you know you've had supper and and uh
you jump into bed you know you lower the
thermostat and you jumped into bed and
you're under the covers and all of a
sudden you say oh no I forgot to lock
the
door oh it's so nice and warm under
these covers I just hate to get out to
lock the door I've lived here for 25
years and the thief has never come in 25
years so the person stays in bed lo and
behold unexpectedly while everybody in
the house is sleeping the thief comes
and he founds the door open he goes in
and he steals uh the you know the
television praise the Lord uh he he
steals the video camera he steals your
cell phone he steals some money oh he he
has a Heyday is does anybody in the
house know that the thief has come no
because everybody's what sleeping that's
why Jesus said watch he's not saying
watch for the second coming he's saying
watch for the close of
probation when do the people inside the
house realize that the thief has been
there is there a period of time that
passes between when the thief comes and
when the people discover the thief has
come yes when do they discover it in the
morning when they wake up but then it is
too late you know the whole Christian
world thinks that they can be saved up
to the moment that Jesus is coming in
the clouds you know Jesus I'm Yours lord
it's not going to happen that way
because probation will close before the
second coming of Jesus and there will be
a severe time of trouble in
between yeah no Christians don't believe
that so Matthew 24 one of the SDA
Church's favorite chapters Jesus was
supposedly
saying watch for the close of
probation since he cited
Noah that's what we're to
believe but did you catch how the appeal
here actually backfires on the SDA
system well some of you may not know SDA
theology but this backfires on them
badly notice Jesus's words again
Matthew 24:
36-41 but concerning that day and hour
no one knows not even the angels of
Heaven nor the son but the father only
for as were the days of Noah so will be
the coming of the son of man for as in
those days before the flood they were
eating and drinking marrying and giving
in marriage until the day when Noah
entered the
Ark and they were unaware until the
flood came and swept them all
away so will the coming of the son of
man then two men will be in the field
one will be
taken and one
left two women will be grinding at the
Mill one will be taken and one
left thus the reading of God's holy word
so question who are the ones that are
taken the wicked
not the
righteous in the flood of Noah it was
the Wicked that were taken by
destruction Jesus uses this as a picture
of the coming of the son of man and says
that the wicked will be unaware and when
he returns they'll be swept
away this is perfectly consistent with
his own teaching in that same gospel
about his kingdom that when he returns
he's rewarding his people and casting
and throwing the wicked out of his
kingdom into outer Darkness
the Christians aren't taken that's what
most western American Christians or or
you know Western modern Christians today
have the idea around Mr bour not the
idea that they can just get right with
God when they see him in the
clouds but that the Christians are
whisked off some other place and they're
the ones taken to go off somewhere else
like you guys
teach but the wicked are the ones that
are swept away and taken
not that it will take seven days for
Michael to get here after standing up
which is supposed to prove the trip back
to heaven will take seven days and that
the 7-Day time span of the AVST Jesus
getting here um during that period
there'll be a time of trouble which will
end when Jesus gets here and kills all
the wicked by the brightness of his
power and those that made it through
having a totally sinless character will
then be taken to heaven for a thousand
years no the taking that happens in
Matthew 24 and Noah's flood is of the
wicked not the righteous Noah his and
his family got off the ark to inherit
the earth after the wicked had been
taken and thrown out of the
Kingdom which is a picture of when Jesus
returns the wicked will be thrown out of
Christ's Kingdom into outer Darkness
God's people will inherit the earth not
be taken and whisked off somewhere else
for a thousand years now there's going
to be changes
made but then he said Christians believe
they can get right with God at the
second
coming Stephen where is your Source on
this I would love to see some of these
claims they make where it's like all
those he said all the Christians out
there just these vague Hasty
generalizations I'd love to see your
Source whether it be Protestant Catholic
Orthodox I I don't know a single
Christian confession of faith that
states
this but actually very plainly they all
put forth
that the call is to repent and believe
the gospel because there's coming a day
in which God's going to judge the world
in
righteousness not oh just wait until you
see him in the clouds
and I don't know maybe he heard from
Individual oneoff people somewhere but
no serious Christian tradition teaches
this folks if you're an Adventist this
is a
caricature so just Christians don't
believe this I'm just telling you I
don't what he means is Downstream from
what we just looked
at because Ellen said that no change of
character will come at the second coming
that's what probation now is for for you
to develop a sinlessly perfect character
that will be locked in for eternity and
unlike them the
Adventists Christians believe
glorification will happen at the return
of Christ which won't only impact a
person's physical makeup but also their
character will Etc
again they Short Circuit the order of
Salvation and they try and put
glorification before the return of
Christ because one has to be able to get
to a sinlessly perfect state currently
to be determined if you're fitted for
heaven and shown worthy of the reward
this is why folks when I hear them
dogging on Roman Catholic theology I'm
just like dude you're worse your guys's
theology is
worse it's such a joke that they think
we know the Pope's the
Antichrist yet it's like dude your
theology is worse than
them they teach Works
salvation no you guys teach Works
salvation you're not even in the
discussion on Merit and and what is even
going on there based on what you you're
saying you're saying and teaching that
God showed this woman that a person has
to get to a glorified State before the
return of Christ you have zero business
talking about purgatory
or such a joke it's just it's such a
joke folks I don't take this system
seriously in that regard that's why I
take the posture I do this movement has
had a long time to get their ducks in a
row it is time for a Stern
talking this movement has zero business
pointing the fingers at everyone
else no clue what they're talking about
no clue what they're criticizing yet
anyone that points out anything in their
system they're the ones misrepresenting
they don't know what they're talking
about yeah you're kidding yourselves but
he caricatured what the Christian uh he
is referring to means when they if they
say this and made it seem like a
normative belief amongst Christians that
they can just get right with God at the
second coming and in the meantime eh
just do their own thing which is
silly like oh they don't believe in
sanctification at all we've looked at
this before where we have leaders in
this movement when I was in SDA
University some of the things that they
said I'm just like I'm sitting there I'm
a Baptist at the time I'm like sitting
there listening I talked with one of my
teachers I'm not going to name who it
was after class one time and I was like
okay and I was chill about it but I'm
like do you understand that you like
completely misrep like 100% guaranteed
you completely misrepresenting what
Christians believe but no Ellen White
claimed
it Ellen White claimed it so he's going
with that Authority it doesn't matter
what the facts actually are he literally
said that the seventh day VST are the
last remaining group that believes in
the second coming the literal physical
second coming this is what they teach
and yet you'll point this stuff out like
I did in a video some months ago and
Adventist got all up in a tizzy and say
I don't know what I'm talking about and
I'm
lying it just this movement scrambles
your brain get out of this movement
folks it's not Christian it's not
Christian I feel like we look at this
quote every week at this point but once
again because it's important on this
subject great controversy p
623 quote now while our great high
priest is making the atonement for us we
should seek to become perfect in
Christ not even by a thought could Our
Savior be brought to yield to the power
of Temptation Satan finds in human
hearts some point where he can gain a
foothold some sinful desires cherished
by means of which his Temptations assert
their power but Christ declared of
himself the prince of this world cometh
and hath nothing in me John
14:30 Satan could find nothing in the
Son of God that would enable him to gain
the victory he had kept his father's
Commandments and there was no sin in him
that Satan could use to his
Advantage this is the condition in which
those must be found who shall stand in
the time of
trouble close
quote so while the investigative
judgment is going on
probation is
open once it closes the time of trouble
begins if you're not found excuse
me if you're not found to be in an
identical condition that Jesus
was totally sinless not even a thought
could be brought to
Temptation you're not going to make it
through this coming time of trouble
so next time you see an Adventist make
sure to ask if they're sinlessly perfect
yet see how long it takes for them to
get squeamish because they know deep
down but at the same time they know but
I'm not trying to just like I'm not just
trying to seek to live however yeah
right so you understand there's some
Nuance here it's not just this false
binary of if you disagree with the sdas
you just are
Lawless but next time you see them ask
them if they're sinlessly perfect yet
and if not why not
because Ellen claimed it's not that you
can't keep the law but that you don't
want to we've looked at that before we
saw in part one the review in heral said
anyone that says they're trying their
best to keep the Commandments is a moral
and doesn't actually walk with
God because God's people are actually
identified by those who have overcome
and are completely keeping the
commandments so make sure to ask them if
they've arrived at glorification and
they're no longer falling short of God's
glory because if not their own system
says they're not prepared for what the
system claims is coming uh any day
now remember Ellen said earlier we're
about to enter
in any moment now all right get busy you
better get busy yeah keep running on the
hamster
wheel after this what sounds like a
noble cause but is actually a
deception which is why you need to flee
this mess and come become a Christian
learn actual Christian teaching and
theology we prepare for that time of
trouble by the way that's going to be
our next study together we're going to
study about that time of trouble in fact
let's say a few things about the time of
trouble you see Satan complains that God
has never allowed him to fully Implement
his style of government he says to God
you always interfere you don't give me
free reain if you allowed me free reain
to attack your PE your people you would
see that they serve you not because they
love you they serve you because of the
Loaves and the fishes but you just don't
let me get at them but if you gave me
just one chance to have full control of
the planet I would show that my style of
government is better than
yours so what is God going to
do God is going to say is that the case
you remember the story of job by the way
in our next lecture we're going to take
a closer look at that story of job that
is a prophetic
story are all of the Heavenly beings
observing what is happening in this
story in the Book of Job is the Heavenly
jury there yeah and Satan comes he says
oh you know job serves you of course
he's blameless and perfect because you
give him everything you don't let me
touch him you protect him but he serves
you out of self-interest if you allowed
me access to him he would blaspheme you
to your face now God could have said
you're a liar and left it at that and
the Heavenly beings probably would have
wondered um what is God afraid of so God
says okay go for it only you can't touch
him and so the devil takes everything
away from job and then you have a second
meeting in heaven uh the Heavenly beings
have seen that God is right because job
says God gave and God has taken away
prais be the name of the Lord in this
job did not sin and so when it when you
have the second meeting uh God says oh
have you seen my servant job he's still
faithful in spite of the fact that you
turned me against him ha the devil says
of course because you didn't let me
touch him but if you let me touch him
you would see he serves you because
you're good to
him God could say you're a liar don't
believe him but God knows that the
Heavenly beings would say well you know
maybe maybe the devil is right so God
says go for it do whatever you want to
him except I will not allow you to kill
him because if you kill him the trial is
over and so the devil goes out and he
afflicts job with boils from the tip of
his head to the bottom to the soles of
his feet he loses the support of his
wife he loses the support of his friends
and he even appears to lose the support
of God and he cries out chapter after
chapter why have you turned against me
oh God but he doesn't give up his faith
he says I know my redeemer lives he says
though he slay me yet yet while I trust
in him he never lets go of the hand of
God even though he he's asking why have
you forsaken me incidentally did Jesus
asked that same question why have you
forsaken me absolutely Jesus went
through the experience of
job wow right out of the
gate he claimed that Satan claims that
God
interferes preventing him from fully
implementing his style of government
notice he didn't even try to get
biblical support for these even out of
context
claims oh he tried to cite from job and
he cited periodic verses from job but
did you catch all the adventism that
were in
there my goodness man it's just amazing
how they can just read the Bible and
think well that's just what it says no
dude that is not what the story of Job
says at all
because this is whole cloth from the
great controversy narrative not
scripture nowhere does Scripture say
that Satan is Waring with God over the
Ten Commandments which is what this
whole interaction is apparently
predicated upon that's what job is about
is about Satan and God Waring about the
the government in
heaven and so Satan's being allowed to
do these things because it's ultimately
a part of the Great controversy and
Satan's accusations and Jesus is being
you know
exalted
no nowhere does Scripture say anywhere
that Satan's Waring with God over the
Ten Commandments and he said they needed
to be changed couldn't be kept and his
form of self-governance is superior to
that of gods where in the Bible does it
say that Satan says to God you always
interfere with what he's trying to do
namely establish a government of
self-governance
it
doesn't this is another standard
Adventist move take a general claim that
Satan is the accuser of God's people for
example and then hitch on to that a
truckload of great controversy claims
that are supposed to be biblical because
even though scripture doesn't say it
well you know doesn't necessarily
contradict the Bible it's just extra
details from God through Ellen White
that supplement the Bible the Lesser
light to the greater light
no that's just a way of saying you're
correct miles it's not in the Bible but
I believe it and it doesn't appear to
contradict the Bible okay own that stop
lying and saying we only believe the
Bible no you use the Bible like a
vitamin as a
supplement to your worldview this
product that you've bought from this
organization and some of you have
invested invested decades into this
product and now you're committing the
sunken cost fallacy where you think well
it's been 30 years so at this point no
no
no swatman doesn't even come close to
passing the test of a prophet God God's
word says not even
Entertainer and if she was in God's
economy to be perfectly honest she'd
have been stoned to death not exactly
the person I'm going to go to for an
alleged infallible interpretation but
that's what he did here nowhere in job
or any of the other places in Scripture
that they point to say Satan is an
accuser who is accusing God about the
Ten Commandments not being fair him
wanting to overthrow God's government by
setting up his own
Etc
notice Patriarchs and Prophets page
quote from the first the great
controversy had been upon on the law of
God Satan had sought to prove that God
was unjust that his law was faulty and
that the good of the universe required
it to be changed in attacking the law he
aimed to overthrow the authority of its
author in the controversy it was to be
shown whether the Divine statutes were
defective and subject to change or
perfect and immutable close
quote this is what Mr bore is putting
forth not scripture because the Bible
does not say this job does not say
this but this does go back to the
central claims of the great controversy
worldview which is that Jesus came to
silence these accusations prove that the
law can't change and that Satan is a
liar which as I've shown countless times
is exactly what they teach about why
Jesus incarnated the Adventist Jesus
that is not the real Christ again Spirit
of Prophecy volume one which is more
than likely Steph is citing from
here quote he talking about Satan left
the immediate presence of the father
dissatisfied and filled with every envy
against Jesus Christ this is the
paragraph after she's just said that God
the Father called all the Heavenly hosts
together before the throne to make an
announcement that the son was being
conferred with special
honor that he was exalted and given
Authority and power he didn't previously
possess
and all the Angels rejoiced at this and
bowed their heads and Satan followed
along as well but deep in his heart he
had bitterness and jealousy and she
talks about his thoughts that he had
this paragraph then
follows after this event Satan then
leaves the presence of the father
dissatisfied and filled with envy
against Jesus Christ concealing his real
purposes he assembled the Angelic host
he introduced his subject which was
himself
as one aggrieved he related the
preferences God had given Jesus to the
neglect of
himself he told them that henceforth all
the sweet Liberty the Angels had enjoyed
was at an end oh no this Jesus being
given this Authority now you're going to
be he's a dictator a tyrant you're going
to lose your Liberty and
freedom that's what he started telling
the
angels for had not a ruler been
appointed over them to whom they from
henceforth must yield servile
honor no no there was no change in Jesus
this was this was just a meeting
where the father was just revealing
what's always been the case that's the
SDA defense no folks Ellen White at this
time didn't believe Jesus was equal with
the father
ontologically so here she has Satan
saying for had not a ruler been
appointed over them oh no he was always
over them right because appointed
doesn't actually mean appointed just
like when in testimonies for the church
Volume 8 when she says that he was made
equal with the father no no it means
he's always been equal with the father
yeah you can't trust Your Lying
Eyes For Those Christians out there that
are just curious you you can't you have
to understand that when you read that
you can't actually believe the words if
you're an Adventist you can if you're an
Adventist you can't but but but not if
you're you're you're being critical cuz
that's going to that's going to affect
the cash cow so we can't have
that so you can't just believe the
words he stated to them that he had
called them together to assure them that
he had no long uh that he no longer
would submit to this invasion of his
rights and theirs that never would he
again bow down to Christ that he would
take the honor upon
himself which should have been conferred
upon
him and would be the commander of all
who would submit to follow him and obey
his
voice there was contention among the
Angels Satan and his sympathizers were
striving to reform the government of
God they were discontented and unhappy
because they could not look into his
unsearchable wisdom and ascertain his
purposes in exalting the son
Jesus and endowing him with such
unlimited power and
command they rebelled against the
authority of the son close
quote so Jesus wasn't already the ruler
over Satan from eternity past he was
made the ruler over him and God the
Father demanded that obedience and honor
be given to him this made Satan or
Lucifer jealous and he sought to do
what take the honor upon himself that
was conferred Upon Jesus
Jus this is the second time in two pages
she's used this word conferred to refer
to Jesus being given Authority that he
did not possess the other is back on
page 17 which is what I mentioned
earlier it's like in the first paragraph
on that same page she also said that
power devolved onto
Christ look up the word
devolved oh in the 19th century it had
some other obscure complete opposite
definition folks all these terms refer
to something being bestowed and given to
someone which means they didn't always
have it yet this movement wants to tell
us they affirm the Trinity that they
believe in the true Christ Etc I'm sorry
stop insulting our
intelligence my give a damn with this
organization busted a long time ago the
sort of every turn you're an idiot you
can't believe anything you're reading
you don't know how to read you don't
actually study it's all out of context
all of this stuff not going to work
anymore you got to understand folks I'm
speaking right now to the guys up in
Tacoma Park that watch this platform you
know who you
are we can read this is not some
Advanced narrative that requires
doctoral degrees to understand you guys
are supposed to be the movement that we
don't need an
expert you don't need an expert to read
the Bible remember we just saw that a
couple weeks ago that's a deception from
Satan
that's a heresy according to Ron
Kelly yet you need an expert to
understand the writings of Ellen
White and you do need an expert actually
to read the Bible because she's the
infallible interpreter and without her
you'll be left to all sorts of confusion
and
division just it's never ending never
ending this jealousy by Satan though
then led to him supposedly convincing
other angels to join in his Rebellion
against God's government seeking to
overthrow it and the newly exalted Jesus
who was endowed with unlimited power and
command even over
Satan none of this is in the Bible none
of this and it presents a false god
that's not
real but all of that is supposed to be
supported by
job
what job doesn't say that God allowed
Satan to do these things because he knew
that the Heavenly beings would doubt God
if he rebuked Satan as a liar like talk
about grasping its straws but this is
how it works Christian cite a couple
Bible passages so it's like oh okay the
story of job and then all these little
details along the way that the Bible
doesn't say but they don't contradict
the
Bible notice he also mentioned the other
Heavenly beings and he says if God would
have just cast Satan down as a liar
they would have thought what is God
afraid
of this is another Central aspect to
this narrative and it's also coming from
Ellen White it's the answer that they
will give as to why the great
controversy is allegedly going on just
like Steven did
there had God just blotted Satan out
upon his Rebellion it would have proven
his accusations to be correct God's at
Tyrant his laws unfair Etc which would
cause the other Heavenly beings to doubt
God and maybe think Satan was correct
after all so God's letting it play out
to ultimately clear his name which is
the entire thesis of Steven B's series
which is titled the great Cosmic
controversy how God clears his name of
all false
charges and job is appealed to to say
all the Heavenly beings were watching
this take place and Satan was allowed to
do what he did with job because it was a
part of the Great controversy and God
clearing his name none of that is in the
text they only say this because they
have this preconceived backdrop that
they bring to the Bible and seek to read
it into wherever they can Ellen
continued the tail end of the chap of
chapter
one Spirit of Prophecy volume one page
quote good Angels wept to hear the words
of Satan and his exalting boasts God
declared that the rebellious should
remain in heaven no longer their high
and happy state had been held upon
condition of obedience to the law which
God had given to govern the high order
of
intelligences but no provision had been
made to save those who should venture to
transgress his law Satan grew bold in
his rebellion and expressed his contempt
of the Creator's law this Satan could
not
bear he claimed that Angels needed no
law but should be left free to follow
their own will which would ever guide
them right that law was a restriction of
their Liberty and that to abolish law
was one great object of his standing as
he
did the condition of the Angels he
thought needed
Improvement not so the mind of God who
had made laws and exalted them equal to
himself
who had made laws and exalted them equal
to
himself the happiness of the Angelic
host consisted in their perfect
obedience to law each had his special
work assigned him and until Satan
rebelled there had been perfect order
and harmonious action in heaven then
there was war in heaven the Son of God
the prince of heaven and his loyal
Angels engaged in conflict with the arch
Rebel and those who United with him the
son of God and true loyal Angels
prevailed and Satan and his sympathizers
were expelled from Heaven all the
Heavenly Host acknowledged and adored
the God of Justice not a taint of
rebellion was left in heaven all was
again peaceful and harmonious as
before close quote so Christian
understand in this system they have
deified the
law and there you see
why the law is a liter Idol in Adventist
theology it's not just a reflection of
God's character which is language that
they took from some of the Protestant
reformers and English Puritans like they
always did and then filter it through
the great controversy
theme no no she's saying God made laws
and exalted them equal to
himself Satan Rebels against these
Eternal laws telling the Angels they
need no law but can be a law unto
themselves
yet it was obedience to these exalted
laws that there was perfect order and
Harmony in heaven but then war broke out
Michael the Archangel and his angels
they claim versus Satan and his angels
and the support for this is supposed to
be Revelation this is what they'll point
to they'll say well war broke out in
heaven with Michael yet this here is
supposed to be before the creation of
the
earth that doesn't come until the next
chapter chapter two which is about the
creation of the Earth
at the end of the uh of this chapter
chapter one she says the father and the
son created the Earth as a probationary
test for man in the great controversy to
see if they would be loyal and vindicate
God's law and character if they were
they'd be made equal with the angels
meaning they would have a place in
heaven among those that are keeping
these exalted laws that are equal to
God that was the first probation so
they'll talk about Jesus coming Len
White did to give a second probation and
this is why I say it is a doover at the
Covenant of works because they don't
understand the timeline correctly or
rather creation correctly because they
have this whole pre-earth origin story
that informs all of this
stuff when Revelation says war broke out
in heaven it's not talking about before
the creation of the
earth yet that's the sort of thing that
they're going to point to in scripture
to try and make some sort of attempt to
justify
this like get
this she gave birth to a son a male
child who will rule all the nations with
an iron scepter and her child was
snatched up to God and to his throne the
woman fled Into the Wilderness to a
place prepared for her by God where she
might be taken care of for 1260 days
then war broke out in heaven Michael and
his angels fought against the dragon and
the dragon and his angels fought back
but he was not strong enough and they
lost their place in heaven
that's not before the creation of the
earth
folks this war between Michael and the
angels fighting the dragon and his
angels leading to their banishment is at
the point is at a point in the church's
history it's like you don't have to get
into what you think the woman is the
dragon etc for this Con this conclusive
fact to be true yet like we saw with
stepen they'll appeal to General
statements in scripture and hitch entire
Concepts and ideas to them despite the
timeline being entirely off on the
concept they do the same thing with
Jesus being exalted they'll point to to
post
Incarnation where as a man he's added
unto himself the word has now added unto
himself human nature and as a man who
fulfilled all righteousness was then
exalted and and made King to rule over
what he won and accomplished they'll
take that and try and pour it in well
Jesus was exalted because the Bible says
over here so that supports this prear
prior to the Incarnation
like no like talk about Bible Butchery
it's just all word association there was
war in heaven so that justifies well
this is pre- Earth origin story no and
the reason I'm making a big deal out of
this is because well twofold one they
need all this to be true for their
system to
operate the statements regarding the
start of the great controversy are
foundational namely Jesus being exalted
to be made equal with the Father which
triggers Satan being jealous or Lucifer
and becoming Satan to then start the
great controversy without all that there
is no God clearing his name of all the
false
charges yet you'll point this out to to
their Scholars who are going to balk and
scoff some of them you know who you
are acting like well you can just kind
of ignore this thing or like I don't
have to justify this or I yeah you do
it's not just a given like what
well that's one they need all this in
their system for it for the whole thing
to function smoothly that's why I'm
making a big deal out of this but two we
have to supposedly believe this message
or we're going to be
damned it's not just a theory that you
have to believe Christian now all this
is connected all of this stuff is
connected you have to adopt and believe
this
system which is why bore is bringing all
of it all of it up together it's a
system and if one of the links in this
chain breaks it falls apart it's not
like
Christianity I've used this analogy
before it's like you have two houses
adventism is not it's in a different
house on a different
Foundation Christians are all in one
house on the same Foundation but in that
house you have varying
rooms and you might come out of your
room and wrestle with your brother and
give him a noogie out in the common area
but at the end of the day you're going
back to your
room and you might be off on something
and a p it's like a picture falling off
the wall like oh shoot and I learned
this and I reformed on it and changed my
belief you know my my belief on
that so I put the picture you know back
up on the wall in the Adventist
system it's not like
that all of these claims are not pict
falling off the wall their
pillars collapsing their support beams
collapsing because if they're off on the
the the close of probation well that
throws off the investigative judgment
that throws off the scapegoat that we're
about to see it throws off all these
things because their whole system is not
built on the foundation that the
apostles laid the apostles didn't lay
such a weak fragile house of cards that
if every single theory that you have
doesn't all line up and every
interpretation that you have and every
spin on everything that you have if
every single one of those things doesn't
check out it falls apart and that's why
Herbert Douglas in Ministry magazine
December 2000 called it mutually
supportive
clusters you have to have all of this
stuff for it to work which is why it's
all foundational in their system and
it's seen as
salvational when you claim to have the
theological God
Particle The Theory of Everything the
mind of God I realize a lot of Adventist
are not aware of these claims glad I
could help you
out and my eternal Destiny depends on
accepting this and joining you yeah I'm
GNA be
hypercritical I'm not just going to go
along with that without analyzing I did
that for many years as an Adventist and
if you're an Adventist that's what they
depend on
you not using your critical thinking
faculties which is why I'm doing so for
you hoping that it will click for some
of you the Bible tells us that after
Michael stands up after Jesus begins to
Reign there's going to be a time of
trouble such as never was since there
was a nation even to that time notice
how it's described in Matthew chapter 24
and verses 21 and 22 Matthew 24: 21 and
22 Jesus described this tribulation in
terms similar to Daniel 12:1 it says for
then there will be Great Tribulation
such as has not been since the beginning
of the world until this time no nor ever
shall be and it's going to be so
terrible according to verse 22 that
unless those days were shortened no
flesh would be saved but for the elect
those days will be what shortened now
listen up folks
God is going to allow Satan to afflict
his people he is going to allow the
devil to try them and test them to the
utmost they will lose everything like
job did they will lose possessions they
will lose houses they will lose lands
they will lose their health they will
lose the support of family and friends
and they will even begin to fear that
they have lost their best friend which
is God and they will struggle with
whether they have any sin
that stand between them and God the
devil will be given free reign except
that God will say to the devil you can
test them to the utmost so that the
Heavenly Universe can see that they
serve me because they love me and not
out of self-interest is God giving a
revelation of his character in contrast
to the character of Satan in the time of
trouble he most certainly is and we're
going to study this a little bit more in
our next lecture together so the devil
will be allowed to implement his plan
without any interference by God except
that God would not allow his people to
be
slain God's people will go through an
experience similar to that of job and
they will not let loose of the hand of
the
Lord so notice how the Adventist system
reads the
text Matthew 24 is supposed to be about
the Seventh Day Adventist Jesus is
preaching about them to a Jewish
audience of people there on the
mount and Jesus is essentially saying
way off into the future there's going to
be this group of people called the
Seventh Day Adventist that will violate
my word by setting dates for my return
something I literally said in this
sermon to not do but they're my new
people with a present truth message and
they will um lose everything because
great persecution is going to come upon
them from the whole world for their
allegiance to their novel concept of
Sabbath
keeping now I'm obviously poking fun
when I say this but it's to make a
point what Steven bour just put forth is
exactly what we're supposed to
understand is in focus in Jesus's sermon
and that's what he's telling his
immediate audience
allegedly I I mean this is a horribly
anachronistic reading of the text has
zero application to the people Jesus was
speaking to that were physically there
listening
why is any of what Steven bour just said
pertinent to a first century Jewish
Christian convert in the Middle
East it
wasn't he read Matthew 24 with a great
controversy lens and inferred all sorts
of things out of the text that aren't in
Focus but sound like they could support
the great controversy narrative so that
must be what the text is talking
about also notice how he read sinless
perfectionism into the text that is
unsurprisingly coming from Ellen White
and her claiming that this is what is in
focus in this text but not from the text
itself zero biblical Exposition was done
to prove that Jesus told the audience
present that the time of trouble will be
a period where the elect will be
struggling in the final steps of being
totally sinless by following Jesus
Through The Sanctuary they'll be like
job and lose everything and the devil
will be given free reign to try and
tempt them but will
fail we looked at the quote earlier from
great controversy page
423 that's what's going on here but the
text does not say
this Christian Adventists will just
assert things often times and you need
to press them on
it many of those who are you know these
staunch Defenders of adventism that you
know that take the the posture that
they're interpretation and claim is is
default and it's everyone else's duty to
prove otherwise again another thing
that's entirely
backwards no the onus is on them to
demonstrate that the text is saying this
when that isn't
present nothing Jesus says proves the
SDA description of the time of trouble
because again it's not just this general
idea that well there's going to be a
time of
trouble well let's say it did
okay so Jesus is telling this Jewish
audience about a time when seventh day
Adventists are going to be vindicating
God's character 2,000 years into the
future where they will be persecuted by
the whole world after a death decree
Goes Forth to have them killed for going
to church on Saturday and they'll lose
everything they have for this but those
who got to a totally sinless condition
before probation closed they'll make it
through this time of trouble where Satan
will be freed to try and tempt them to
curse God but will fail question
mark nowhere in this text is job
mentioned referenced alluded to or even
connected such that the
SAS can are to make the time of trouble
about representing job and they're going
to face a time of trouble like he did
because Satan's going to be loose to do
so I mean
seriously nothing in Matthew 4 says the
time of Trouble Is God letting there be
a stark contrast between his character
and Satan's character nothing in
scripture anywhere says this because
God's character was clearly demonstrated
at Calvary regardless of Satan or what
any of creation thinks for that
matter for God so loved the world that
he gave his only begotten son John 3:16
it was at Calvary God was shown to be
both the just and the justifier of the
one who has faith in Jesus Christ Romans
3:26 the the heavens declare the glory
of God Psalm 19:1 the the biblical
writers folks did not have this Paradigm
where God is on
trial they didn't go around they went
around declaring this as a fact Jesus
Christ is
alive here's who he is here's what he
did not to prove himself or vindicate
his or character or the god the father's
character Christ revealed the mystery of
godliness was seen amongst the Angels
Vindicated by the spirit AKA proven uh
to be who he claimed that he
was believed on in the world and taken
up to Heavens in glory 1 Timothy
3:16 God is Not on trial for you or any
other creature for that matter to judge
him and determine if you think he is who
he says he is
furthermore where is the historical
grammatical method that Ted Wilson
insists as the only approved hermeneutic
in the SDA
church can somebody find me the
Adventist that actually utilizes this
where where is the Adventist that
understands what that
means again to the SDA theologians up in
Tacoma Park that watch our platform hey
there
gentlemen is Steven bour utilizing the
hgm
here why do you all tell people that you
uphold something that's Protestant in
nature yet you very clearly do
not this is a seemingly consistent
pattern with you all that at a certain
point starts to come off as knowingly
deceptive none of the audience present
when Jesus was preaching ing this had a
great controversy worldview and all of
what Mr bour is presenting is informed
by that heck Jesus Christ himself
doesn't even have a great controversy
worldview and yet it was allegedly given
by him to the SDA Church yeah
okay in fact Ellen White has explained
that God's people will go through a
similar experience to the experience
that Jesus went through in Gethsemane
and on the cross let me read you this
statement from review and Herald April
14th
1896 where Ellen White is describing
what is going to happen uh with with
God's people the forces of Darkness of
the powers of Darkness will Unite with
human agents who have given themselves
unto the control of
Satan and the same
SCS that were exhibited at the trial
rejection and crucifixion of Christ will
be
revived wow so are God's people going to
cry out why have you forsaken me
absolutely do you know when Jesus hang
on the cross he had nothing not even his
clothes he had lost everything and it
appeared like he'd lost the support of
his father too but his father was close
by Jesus did not go by his feelings he
went by the promises of his father that
if he was faithful his father was going
to resurrect him on the third day that's
why he commanded his Spirit into the
hands of his
father no Mr bore Adventist will not go
through a similar experience that Jesus
went through I mean what bro what are
you talking about
man you won't even experience a fraction
of what Jesus
experienced the sinless Eternal Son of
God that became sin so that his people
might become the righteousness of God
the SDA church has to be one of the
least persecuted people groups in the
history of the
world the fact that SDA leaders continue
to Pedal the idea that they'll be the
central focus of the greatest
persecution that's ever taken place on
the
planet it would be downright comical if
it weren't so
sad all the SDA caught up in this
paranoia and fear as their life waste
away and they dwell on this fairy tale
that abuses the Bible to try and support
it Mr bore Adventists can't even handle
answering
adventism we live rentree fre and I
don't know how many SDA they just
bombard us with hate mail and just
constantly we get inundated with
comments from Adventists that claim
they're being
attacked persecuted oh oh
oh oh my theology was
critiqued give me a freaking break
the vast majority I engage with can't
even have their theology critiqued
without whining and crying that they're
being
attacked such a joke man you don't know
how many people out there attack my
system of theology
boohoo get over it who
cares if this is supposed to be the
movement that's filled with sinlessly
perfect people that will withstand the
greatest act of persecution the world
has ever seen give me a break man
Ellen White had a chronic habit of
making parallels between Adventist and
Jesus and the Wicked with the Jews of
Jesus's day
sick so it's no surprise that she even
takes the suffering of Christ and says
Adventists will experience something
similar they will have arrived at a
sinlessly perfect State like Jesus
supposedly and they'll be persecuted
like he was
P but I want to point out something
Stephen said Jesus commended his Spirit
to the father knowing that if he was
faithful the father would
resurrected so Ellen White taught that
only the father could resurrect
Jesus well except then she contradicts
herself
later and for the AVST that want to say
I reject Ellen White well it's in the
SDA Bible commentary too
notice
qu Christ submitted to crucifixion
although the Heavenly Host could have
delivered him the Angels suffered with
Christ God himself was crucified with
Christ for Christ was one with the
father those who reject Christ those who
will not have this man to rule over them
choose to place themselves under the
rule of Satan to do his work as his bond
slaves yet for them Christ yielded up
his life on
Calvary now the SDA Bible commentary
he who died for the sins of the world
was to remain in the Tomb the a lotted
time he was in that Stony prison house
as a prisoner of divine Justice he was
responsible to the judge of the universe
he was bearing the sins of the world and
his father
only could release
him close
quote so God was crucified with Christ
but Christ is God seemingly putting
forth some sort of Mo almost like a
modalistic idea of the godhead that
Jesus and the father are one and he the
father was crucified with Christ just
bizarre shows this woman had no clue
what she was talking about but very
plainly she
says the
father
alone this is another one of those areas
Christian where no no alone doesn't
actually mean alone it actually means
with multiple
persons made equal doesn't mean made
equal it means he always had it devolved
doesn't actually mean Authority given
from a higher authority to a lesser
Authority no no no it means they're
already
equal yeah only the father Adventist
will huff and puff and claim they're
being misrepresented AKA we can't read
or understand basic grammar but there it
is no when looked at in total scripture
demonstrates that the resurrection was a
trinitarian
act I can show you where it says the
father resurrected Jesus where Jesus
said he himself would raise himself and
where the spirit is said to have raised
him but
notice after clearing house in the
temple and driving out the money
changers John
2 so the Jews said to him what sign do
you show us for doing these things Jesus
answered them destroy this Temple and in
three
days I I I will raise it up the Jews
then said it's taken 46 years to build
build this
Temple and will you raise it up in 3
days but he was speaking about the
Temple of his body when therefore he was
raised from the dead his disciples
remembered that he had said this and
they believed the scripture and the word
that Jesus had spoken thus the reading
of God's holy word destroy this temple
in three days and I I I will raise it up
Jesus will raise it up this was a
trinitarian act father son and spirit
scripture does not say Jesus commended
his Spirit into the hands of his father
because the father alone could resurrect
him the text does not say this Ellen
White did but not the Bible again
Stephen you are crossing wires sir you
are confusing Ellen White's commentary
with the
Bible her commentary is not even an
exposition of the biblical text but is
cut whole cloth from her vain imaginings
that are then labeled as divinely
inspired commentary on what's present in
the text folks when you hear them try to
say she's just a commentator like
anybody else no no not even
close commentators are doing an
exposition of the text dealing with
what's there and parsing out the meaning
not commenting on what's there and
adding a bunch of stuff not found in the
text claiming it's coming from God but
it's just light that shines on what's
already
there no this isn't of Jesus this is
just her stating things that are not
even stated in the text that you could
never arrive at from the text
itself which is why nine times out of 10
when people like Steven bour are citing
this you get 10 times the amount of
Ellen white-sided to scripture but this
is how some SDA leaders will drop this
stuff into their
presentations and people won't even
catch it he just said that in passing
because he knew that the father would
resurrect
him he even took Jesus being without his
clothes to be a picture for sdas who
like Christ will be sinless lose
everything including their
clothes figuratively speaking of of
course they're going to lose
everything this is
crazy I mean talk about a man- centered
reading of the text how can we look at
Jesus and see
ourselves I mean come on
man Christ being without clothes was
prophesied in the Old Testament folks
this teaches us about the validity of
God's word his promises and that Jesus
is the Messiah that was foretold of in
the law and the prophets and that what
was taking place right in front of them
happened right on schedule and it's the
shity of our salvation and peace with
God that the gospel is
real
notice Psalm 22 it's a Messianic Psalm
this is David crying out but it's
actually foreshadowing and point
pointing to what happened to
Jesus he laments he says I am poured out
like water and all my bones are out of
joint my heart is like Wax it's melted
within my breast my strength is dried up
like a pot shirt and my tongue sticks to
my jaws you lay me in the dust of death
for dogs Encompass me a company of
evildoers encircles me they have pierced
my hands and feet I can count all my
bones they stare and gloat over me
they divide my garments among them and
for my clothing they cast
lots so an a company of evildoers did
indeed surround Christ and Pierce his
hands and feet and then divide up his
garments amongst them and cast lots over
them Matthew
27:35 to read into this
yourself and that you will one day be
like Jesus and have everything taken
from you you'll be like job
so job is now about you too you'll be
totally sinless the entire world hates
you Etc is just honestly borderline
Blasphemous to be perfectly
honest everything that you are hearing
from him is the Bible taught through the
lens of the great controversy
worldview it says the same scenes that
were exhibited at the trial rejection
and crucifixion of Christ will be
revived through yielding to satanic
influences men will be merged into
fiends that is men will become demons
and those who were created in the image
of God who were formed to honor and
glorify their creator will become the
habitation of dragons and Satan will see
in an apostate race his Masterpiece of
evil men who reflect his own image
that's what this world is going to be
like in the time of trouble and you know
sometimes uh preachers try to scare
people into serving the lord and saying
you're not going to have an inter
God's going to leave you here listen
folks we are not going to have anybody
to intercede for our sins but Jesus will
be our
protector because if Jesus is not the
protector nobody would
survive no intercessor he says outright
blatant contradiction of the Bible
irrefutably so so like we saw earlier
the AVST Jesus is not simultaneously a
priest and a king he is a priest right
now and will take off his Priestly
garments in the future and put on kingly
garments when this happens probation has
closed and Jesus is no longer
interceding for
people bore then said some SDA pastors
will use this to scare people but Jesus
as king will be their protector so no
need to
worry after the author of Hebrews
explains that Perfection was not
attainable through the levitical
priesthood but one was foretold that
would be a priest not after Levi but
Judah a tribe that there was nothing
written of in MO uh Moses regarding them
being priests he then says
this this becomes even more evident when
another priest arises in the likeness of
melkisedek who has become a priest not
on the basis of a legal requirement
concerning bodily descent but by the
power of an
indestructible
life for it is witnessed of him quoting
from the Suter you are a priest forever
after the order of
melkisedek for on the one hand a former
commandment is set aside because of its
weakness and uselessness for the law
made nothing perfect but on the other
hand a better hope is introduced through
which we draw near to
God and it was not without an oath for
those who forly became priests were made
such without an oath but this one was
made a priest with an oath by the one
who said to
him the Lord has sworn and will not
change his
mind you are a priest
forever this makes Jesus the guarantor
of a better Covenant the former priests
the Levites were many in number because
they were prevented by Death from
continuing in
office but he holds his
priesthood
permanently because he continues
forever indestructible
life consequently he is able to save to
the uttermost those who draw near to God
through him since he always
lives to make
intercession for
them thus the reading of God's holy word
Jesus is a priest for how
long forever and why is
this because he has an
indestructible life which prevents him
from dying like the
Levites Jesus holds his office
permanently because he lives forever and
it's because of
that that he always lives forever to
make
what intercession for us
because of his indestructible life he
lives forever to make intercession for
his
people what this proves is not only that
Ellen White was wrong and contradicts
the Bible yet again but that the SDA
church does not actually understand the
high Priestly kingly role of Jesus
Christ and this is supposed to be
something that's a h run for them part
of their special truth that they're
restoring now now sorry Adventist you've
been duped it's time to give up this
system that's built on lies manipulation
and Bible twisting have Fidelity to the
word of God over this movement go where
the voice of the shepherd leads it is
not
here this prab of scripture is crystal
clear no amount of twisting will change
the facts I know that their Scholars
love with the book of Hebrews all of a
sudden it's everything's well the Greek
the Greek the Greek yeah all of a sudden
Williams William Miller's principles of
well we don't need that I thought that's
one of the principles right you don't
need an expert you don't need Greek he
just had a
concordance just everywhere
inconsistencies it's like no amount of
trying to use the Greek grammar card
will change these bare facts because the
entire point of the author is comparing
and contrasting Jesus with the Levites
unlike them who died and their
priesthood ended and then had to be
followed up with a successor Jesus will
never die which is why he holds his
office permanently and it's because both
of those facts that he forever lives to
make intercession for his
people Jesus's intercession is also tied
to his role as a king which never ends
it's a simultaneous
role yet they recognize he's going to
rule and Reign forever but that's after
he changes his garments and starts the
role of a
king no you're just having to uphold
1844 at all costs so you're just denying
the blatant plain obvious reading of the
text Jesus's intercession is not a work
of only dealing with sin like the SDA
Church teaches while he was on Earth he
was inaugurated to be a priest at his
baptism dealt with sin by putting it
away at the cross Hebrews 9:26 but
continues as a priest and is inaugurated
at his Ascension as a king where he
assumes his simultaneous role I would
argue he was even a king though while on
Earth still read Matthew 1 the wise men
come to him and call and recognize that
he is a king they himself call him a a
king this
babe but it is Jesus's forever bridging
of the gap between God and man as the
God man
himself he will forever be the God man
who rules and Reigns and keeps his
people into
eternity this is why when we were
listening to Randy Ski's Adam Bomb of
blasphemy some weeks back I got so
worked up the guy claimed the sacrifice
of Christ won't be needed into
eternity and when you realize that they
don't understand the forever
intercession of Christ made possible by
his perfect sacrifice it makes sense
that they could say such a
thing but no and this is
why after probation
closes and the time of trouble is about
to begin a special ceremony takes place
the last ceremony on the day of
atonement it's known as the scapegoat
ceremony you see two goats were chosen
one for the Lord that one was sacrificed
the blood was sh represents the death of
Christ the other uh the other goat the
other male goat was not
slain that goat was was brought to the
entrance to the tent in other words he's
in the court of the sanctuary and the
high priest would come through the most
holy place and then through the holy
place to the door of the Holy place
where the scapegoat was waiting in the
court and you say where does the bible
say that Leviticus 16 and verse 7 tells
us he that is the high priest shall take
the two goats and present them before
the Lord at the door of the Tabernacle
of meeting are you catching the picture
what does the court represent the court
represents the Earth In Heaven There is
no court because the work of the Court
was performed by Jesus on Earth you see
Jesus died on Earth and he resurrected
on Earth and he lived in our camp on
Earth so the Heavenly Sanctuary has a
holy and most holy place but there's no
court because the work represented by
the court was fulfilled by Jesus while
he was here on the Earth are you
following me or not and so where will
the scapegoat be when this is finally
fulfilled he will be on earth and Jesus
the high priest will come out and he
will perform this aasal Ceremony this
scapegoat ceremony he will bring all of
the sins
that were introduced into the sanctuary
through the blood of Jesus all of the
sins that were forgiven and he's going
to bring all of those sins to the
entrance of the Tabernacle of meeting
and he will place both hands on the head
of the scapegoat in this case what does
the scapegoat represent the scapegoat
represents Satan and all of the sins of
the righteous that were placed in the
sanctuary through the blood will be
placed upon the head of the scapegoat
who is ultimately responsible for the
origin and the perpetuation of
sin I challenge any Seventh Day
Adventist in the world to show us where
Leviticus 16 Associates the scapegoat
with responsibility for
sin he's going to say this over and over
and over going into this next section
they always
do I'll give you a hint you're not g to
find it
that has absolutely nothing to do with
the scapegoat and its
function the scapegoat represented
expiation the removal of sin not
responsibility for
it and Two Goats were needed to complete
the picture for the Israelites a dead
goat could not symbolize for them their
sin being taken away only the sin being
paid
for Leviticus 165 doesn't just say Two
Goats were to be taken but both were to
be taken for a single sin
offering Advent will be quick to say
only the Lord's goat was
sacrificed so that means the other goat
wasn't a part of the offering well
that's not the
claim the claim isn't that both were a
sacrifice no both functioned as a
singular sin offering that was required
of the
nation the goats had to be identical and
blemish free like the law required all
sacrifices and
offerings all of
them including for example the ones that
were not living meaning they weren't an
animal such as the ones that involve
fruits it's not just things that are
being killed they'll try and use that
argument too well it's only if they were
being like
killed
no Satan isn't blemish free if you're
going to to be hyper literal about
this and yet Adventists will do all
sorts of mental gymnastics and say Satan
was originally created perfect so
therefore he could be the scapegoat
because well he was originally
sinless just the craziest stretching and
twisting to try and keep any vestage of
this system on life support notice what
Professor uh El Michael Morales
says this is from his book who will
Ascend the mountain of the Lord which is
a Biblical theology textbook on
Leviticus it's a little
weighty but I believe that we have a
smart
audience notice what he writes
quote the scapegoats role should be
understood in conjunction with that of
the goat that is
sacrificed as an elimination right the
azazil goat ritual is often probed in
isolation from a redactional and or
comparative religion
approach within the context of Leviticus
however the right is fully integrated as
part of one complete
ceremony Associated particularly with
the young goat that is
sacrificed for
example while two Rams are also used on
the day of atonement in uh as Ascension
offerings for the Priestly house and for
Israel
respectively yet these two animals are
not brought together in the same fashion
as are the two
goats the text is quite careful to
portray the goats as a
set the high priest takes them both from
the congregation of Israel presents them
both together before Yahweh at the door
of the tent of meeting and then cast
lots for them
both the instructions for the high
priest in Leviticus 165 moreover refer
to both goats together as a single
purification
offering to be sure the expulsion right
is not in offering in the technical
sense nevertheless in removing sin the
scapegoat function fits the precise
significance of sin as purification and
combined with the blood manipulation of
the sacrificed goat completes the
picture of the
atonement indeed there is historical
precedent for understanding these goats
to be identical in appearance and chosen
expressly because of this
likeness as if it were one goat
accomplishing two different aspects of
atonement purification and
experation cleansing from sin's
pollution and the removal of sins
guilt close quote so what Dr Morales
puts forth here is not unique to him and
notice he explicitly states that yes the
scapegoat itself was not an offering in
the technical sense meaning it wasn't
sacrificed no one is claiming this so
Adventist can quit using that defense as
though that's what Christians are saying
both goats function as a single offering
to complete complete the picture of
atonement sin being paid for and then
removed from the people Jesus does both
he's the Fulfillment of all of the laws
sacrifices and offerings not just the
sin offering not just the purification
offering not just the day of atonement
offerings and sacrifices he's the burnt
offering the Free Will offering the
guilt offering
Etc and this is why Leviticus 16:10 says
that the at uh that atonement was made
on the scapegoat
the scapegoat is a part of the atonement
the removal of
sin the same thing is seen in Leviticus
14 by the way with the cleansing of
leprosy which was a ritual that involved
two
doves one was killed and then the live
one was dipped in the blood of the slain
one and then released which would
cleanse the person of their disease same
exact picture taking
place all all of the SDA appeals to
Jewish folklore The Book of Enoch Etc
are grasping at straws but notice also
Steven said that the sins are
transferred to Satan or the sins that
are transferred to Satan are those from
the righteous that were stored in the
sanctuary in heaven and dealt with in
the investigative judgment no we've
looked at this countless times this is a
key area where the typology breaks
down blood was only taken into the
sanctuary on two occasions on says
Leviticus 4 when the priest sinned when
the entire Israelite Community sinned
unintentionally which is what the SDA
Church tries to point to to say that
works for our typology no it
doesn't no it doesn't Ellen White
paralleled it with the daily
ministration for individual penitent
Israelites which has instructions in
Leviticus 4 that are different than when
it was for the the the community
Israelite
Community that's the verse they'll point
to that's referring to the Israelite
Community not just that but that was
only when they sinned
unintentionally but blood was not taken
into the sanctuary for individual
penitent Israelites on a daily basis yet
that's what again that's what Ellen
White claims is the picture for
believers today of what
happens this problem alone foils the
entire concept of Satan being the
scapegoat from their point of view
because they aren't the only ones in
history that have claimed this because
Christian some Adventists are going to
appeal to origin of Alexandria to try
and bolster their view be prepared for
this some SDA try and say origin belied
that Satan was the scapegoat so that
vindicates the avenus
belief and if you call their view
heretical then you have to say origin
was a heretic they try and put you in
this sort of bind like was origin a
heretic then
H okay for starters origin can be wrong
not only can he but he was on a number
of
issues but more importantly origin
didn't hold to the same model of
atonement that SD
do no one did until the 19th century
origin affirmed the ransome theory that
that God paid a ransom to the devil to
free us as hostages he didn't believe
however that Satan bore the sins of
Believers found worthy away as a part of
the expiatory work of sin
furthermore this is the same
origin who popularized the typology that
Jesus barabus at the crucifixion was a
type or picture of the
scapegoat something I tried telling in
SDA Pastor that I debated on this
subject would be a better typology for
him to make than than than trying to
appeal to Leviticus 16 for this but
notice
from his homy on Leviticus
10 quote let us also now attempt to add
something to what was said long ago to
the best of our ability that we may show
how as a type of things to
come this one heot was sacrificed to the
Lord as an offering and the other one
was sent away
living here in the gospels what pilate
said to the priests and the Jewish
people
which of these two do you want me to
send out to you Jesus who is called the
Christ or barabus if you read the NIV it
will tell you barabus his name is Jesus
barabus then all the people cried out to
release barabus but to hand Jesus over
to be killed behold you have a he goat
who was sent living Into the Wilderness
bearing with him the sins of the people
who cried out and said crucify crucify
close quote
yet numerous Adventists that heard me
bring this up in the debate which wasn't
even my argument I'm saying this would
be more consistent for you this would be
a better typology for you to appeal
to yet numerous adven that heard me say
this bed and scoffed while they
themselves try to appeal to origin to
support their
view it's like you can't even make this
up not just this but also look what
origin says regarding the
Wilderness the SDA is try and say it's
the Earth which is what we heard stepen
bore say and it's going to be a desolate
Wasteland well what's origin
say again homy on Leviticus chapter 9
the end of this lot is Wilderness that
is a desolate Place desolate of Virtues
desolate of God desolate of Justice
desolate of Christ desolate of all good
this is him talking about the Wilderness
and the
scapegoat yeah this also isn't what the
SDA church is that the
wildernesses so despite the fact that
origin held a totally different theory
of atonement a different typological
foreshadowing of the scapegoat and a
totally different idea of what the
Wilderness is and what the scapegoat was
actually doing yeah the the SD is
totally Vindicated by appealing to
origin no Christian if you hear them do
this politely let them
know they don't understand what they're
appealing to I don't personally agree
with origin I'm simply showing you all
the sort of defenses that they try and
why they're flawed origin's theory is
not a friend to adventism I can assure
you of this now he's going to give five
reasons why Satan is supposedly the
scapegoat listen very closely now some
people say well Pastor bore Adventists
believe that Satan is their savior
because the sins are placed on the head
of the scapegoat well the fact is that
uh that those who say that are not
careful in their analysis let me tell
you the reason why just because the the
final responsibility for the sins that
Satan LED God's people to commit are
placed on the head of the scapegoat it
doesn't mean that the scapegoat is our
savior Five Points that I want to
mention number
one clearly the two goats are
opposites some Scholars say both goats
represent Jesus no no no it says in
Leviticus chapter 6 16: 8-10 that one is
for the Lord and the other is for azil
incidentally in Jewish tradition and we
don't go by Jewish tradition but it's
interesting to notice that for example
in the book uh Ethiopian Book of
Enoch it states that uh aasil was a
malignant being the originator of sin
and the leader of the rebellious Angels
so the Jews understood that aasil
represent a malignant Spirit furthermore
when the sins are placed upon the
scapegoat the sanctuary had already been
cleansed so so the scapegoat is not
cleansing the sanctuary the blood of
Jesus cleansed the sanctuary and then
the final responsibility is placed on
the head of the scapegoat furthermore
the blood of the scapegoat was not shed
and it says in Hebrews 9:22 that without
the shedding of blood there is no REM
Mission or forgiveness of sins so the
scapegoat was not sacrificed to forgive
sin he bore the ultimate responsibility
for sin and finally the scapegoat was
sent to the Wilderness where there was
no inhabitant you can find that in
Leviticus 16:22 can you think of a
passage in the Book of Revelation where
a certain being is sent to a desolate
Wilderness where there are no
inhabitants Revelation CH 20 it says
that a mighty Angel descends from heaven
with a chain in his hand and he's going
to chain the devil to a desolate Planet
which is without form and void according
to Jeremiah chapter 4 and where all of
his followers are what are dead and so
clearly the one who Bears the ultimate
responsibility for the sins of the
righteous is
Satan yes and Stephen the reason people
say you guys are mingling Satan in with
salvation is because Leviticus 16:10
says the scapegoat had atonement made on
it and they're going to suffer their own
P was that now
sorry Leviticus 16:10 says that the
scapegoat had atonement made on it and
its function and role was that of
removing sin you guys attribute this to
the devil and in trying to to deal with
this
problem the SDA Church writes this in
the footnotes of the fundamental beliefs
book regarding the
subject
quote if azazil represents Satan how can
scripture connect him with the
atonement as the high priest after
having cleansed the sanctuary placed the
sins on azazil who was forever removed
from God's people so Christ after having
cleansed the Heavenly Sanctuary will
place the confessed and forgiven sin of
his people on
Satan who will then be forever removed
from the
saved now they start citing from the SDA
Bible commentary how fitting that the
closing act of the drama of God's
dealings with sin should be a returning
upon the head of Satan of all the sin
and guilt that issuing from him
originally once brought such tragedy to
the lives of those now freed of sin in
by Christ atoning blood thus the cycle
is completed the drama
ended only when Satan the instigator of
all sin is finally removed can it truly
be said that sin is forever blotted out
of God's Universe in this accommodated
sense in this
accommodated sense we may understand
that the scapegoat has a part part in
the atonement Leviticus
16:10 with the righteous saved the
wicked cut off and Satan no more then
not till then will the universe be in a
state of Perfect Harmony as it was
originally before sin entered close
quote right in this accommodated
sense Satan accommodates Jesus in
completing the removal of sin by bearing
it because well he's ultimately
responsible nowhere does Scripture say
this nowhere does Scripture say Satan
Bears the final responsibility for sin
or that the scapegoat represented such
yet he asserted it like five times in
there Adam is blamed for sin Romans 5
not
Satan estas have been so browbeaten
about Satan that he's just inserted all
over the place and given Supreme f FAL
you know this supreme focal role that
makes him the tragic hero in the great
controversy narrative but Mr bore this
is why people say that you guys make
Satan a savior in a tertiary sense
because you do it's that you guys don't
understand what you're claiming when you
say this because you think something
about the scapegoat that's not true it
has nothing to do with responsibility it
has to do with
cleansing removing sin which you
recognize to some degree cuz you say
that he removes it and then you don't
understand how this then is tied to
Salvation it's not a matter of not doing
a careful analysis it's because of doing
a careful analysis
sir your sin isn't removed and your
peace with God accomplished until Satan
takes your sins away that Jesus places
on him making both Jesus and Satan the
finisher of your salvation not God
Alone he said clearly the two goats are
opposites though because one is for the
Lord and the other for
azazil this
assumes azazil is a formal name and it
begs the
question it is assuming what needs to be
demonstrated because this is exactly the
rub azazil is translated as scapegoat in
most translations because it refers to a
function not a personal
figure the SDA position relies on Jewish
folklore and extra biblical trans you
know Traditions that associate Ozil with
a Wilderness demon as a formal name but
the text does not say
this you know he said they don't go by
Jewish tradition yet on this subject
that's what they always appeal to to try
and bolster their
claim this doesn't prove though that
they are clearly opposites the text says
that one is for a sacrifice the other
for an escape
goat what Bor and the SDA present is
that the text is saying one is for God
and the other is for the devil Two Goats
for two different personal
figures but remember the text is very
careful to portray the goats as a
set both taken from the congregation of
Israel both are presented together
before Yahweh at the door of the tent of
meeting and then lots are cast over both
of them both goats together presented as
a single purification offering Leviticus
165 they had to be identical which is
not indicative of
opposites but Mr bore since you guys
take this to be a hyper literal picture
that is an exact one to one on every
point to build out the antitype of your
guys' Sanctuary model when were lots
cast Over Jesus and
Satan what's that
oh oh they they
weren't ah
right we again heard him say
responsibility was placed on Satan as
the scapegoat after the sanctuary had
already been cleansed of sin and that's
supposed to support
this again no sins were not transferred
into the sanctuary in the daily Ministry
of the priests on behalf of individual
penitent Israelites nor does the text
say that the scapegoat bore
responsibility for
sin but Stephen what's fascinating about
this claim is that the same woman you
were citing from
earlier had this to say about the
scapegoat quote some apply the solemn
type the scapegoat to Satan this is not
correct he cannot bear his own
sins at the choosing of
barabus pilate washed his
hands he cannot be represented as the
scapegoat the awful cry uttered with a
hasty awful recklessness by the Satan
inspired multitude swelling louder and
louder reaches up to the throne of God
his blood be upon us and upon our
children Matthew
27:25 Christ was the scapegoat which the
type represents he alone can be
represented by the goat Born Into the
Wilderness he alone over whom death had
not power was able to Bear our
sins close quote
some Christians out there say that Jesus
is the scapegoat step Boris says but no
no no the only defense Christian that
Adventists have to this meaning
typically their their scholarship not
the a average individual SDA that's just
unfortunately been taken captive by this
nine times out of 10 the only defense
they have is that this was never
published therefore it can't it can be
dismissed Steven for sites from her
letters and manuscripts that are not
published all the
time cope harer the woman evidences she
was no different than anyone else she
didn't have the theological God Particle
given to her from God himself which was
the antidote to theological division
this statement is after the great
controversy has already been published
for two
decades finally we heard one of their
favorite proof texts in Revelation 20
Noe Mr bore
nothing in Revelation 20 connects to
Leviticus
16 nothing in Revelation 20 is dealing
with the day of
atonement they have made the day of
atonement this long drawn out thing that
began in 1844 which is the core
issue then I saw an angel coming down
from heaven holding in his hand the key
to the bottomless pit in a great chain
and he sees the dragon that ancient
serpent who is the devil in Satan and
bound him for a thousand years and threw
him into the pit and shut it and sealed
it over him so that he might not deceive
the Nations any longer until the
thousand years were ended after that he
must be released for a little
while this is supposed to prove that
Satan is the scapegoat who Bears
responsibility for sin and like the
scapegoat will be thrown off a mountain
Into the Wilderness aka the Earth which
will be desolate so Jesus is the Angel
here that comes with a chain
the angel in this is supposed to
represent the priest taking
the Mr bore you guys also claim that
Colossians 2 is saying that the
ceremonial law was nailed to the cross I
don't agree with this interpretation but
that's what you guys claim the day of
atonement was a part of the ceremonial
law sir yet you guys don't think it was
nailed to the cross ironically on the
true antitypical day of atonement all
five of those points that he gave all
fail when Jesus returns the second time
he will be free of the stain of sin
because he will have cleansed the
sanctuary and plac the sins where they
belong notice Hebrews chapter 9: 27 and
28 Hebrews 9:27 and 28 and as it is
appointed for men to die once but after
this the Judgment so Christ was offered
once to Bear the sin of many to those
who are eagerly uh waiting for him he
will appear a second time and now notice
this apart from sin for salvation why
will he appear apart from sin because
all of the sins have been placed where
on the head of the scapegoat and then
I'll tell you what the high priest would
do after he had placed all of the
responsibility upon the head of the
scapegoat then the high priest would
return to the most holy place and he
would change his
garments he would take off his high
Priestly
garments and he would
change no I'm going to keep saying
it the scapegoat had nothing to do with
responsibility you can keep repeating it
over and over and over it does not
change the
facts it doesn't change the
facts but he said Hebrews 9 folks
somewhere we spent almost an hour in
part
one and do you remember what the author
is putting forth in verses 28 and
29 notice he left off verse
26 gee I wonder why this is the same
individual that was preaching through
Patriarchs and Prophets supplementing in
Genesis 3 periodically because he's
quoting from the portion that's supposed
to be this divinely inspired commentary
on Genesis 3 and only read half of
Genesis 3:6 because the latter half
contradicts Ellen White and what he was
presenting but like we saw in part one
we looked at this prapy in great detail
again
notice leading up to the verses that he
read for Christ has entered not into
holy places made with hands which are
copies of the true things but into
heaven itself now to appear in the
presence of God on our behalf nor was it
to to offer himself repeatedly as the
high priest enters the holy places every
year with blood not his own for then he
would have had to have suffered
repeatedly since the foundation of the
world but as it is he has appeared once
for all at the end of the
ages to put sin Away by the sacrifice of
himself ah Jesus put sin away
where at the cross where he gave of
himself as a sacrifice one time and this
work did
what put sin
away did not move it to a building in
heaven it didn't transfer
sin hey Mr bore that's
experation that's experation sir the
actual role of the scapegoat the removal
of sin
this is why when he returns it isn't to
deal with sin not because he was dealing
with it in a sanctuary building and
placed it on Satan to take it
away because he already put it away at
the cross not through transferring it to
a heaven to investigate and then
transfer the ones found worthy onto
Satan and those unworthy back onto them
remember what John Owen rightly pointed
out when we looked at his Exposition
last time Christ had the sins of his
people placed on him at Calvary
had he not put that sin away at the
cross he could not have entered into the
presence of God Owen rightly points out
that there's a parallel between Christ
and the levitical priests they had to
make atonement for themselves to
ritually purify themselves before they
could enter into the presence of God for
the
people so Christ the author making the
the parallel to the better this is a
common thing Jesus did this in his
ministry all the time the argument from
the inferior to the Superior or the
superior to the
inferior striking a contrast to prove a
point so because the priest had to make
atonement for themselves to ritually
purify themselves before they could
enter into the presence of God for the
people so Christ sorry so Christ having
our sins placed on him at Calvary also
had to be purified of those to enter
into the presence of God
which is why they were put away at
Calvary and Christ is no longer dealing
with them but is seated as a reigning
and conquering King while all of his
enemies are made a
footstool I'm going to say it again just
because I'm going to keep saying this
for the fifth time now he once again
claimed that responsibility was placed
on the scapegoat this is Central to
their whole thing they have to have
this not found in in the text at
all and then finally he tried pointing
to the priest that after taking the
scapegoat out into the Wilderness had to
come back and change his garments which
were ultimately defiled from the work
Stephen this is not a picture of Jesus
who changes garments out of Priestly
attire into kingly
attire the Levites did not change into
kingly attire they were not Kings at all
in part one and earlier in the
presentation I showed why this is an
error now I know these presentations are
meaty and can be like drinking from a
fire
hose but break them out into sessions if
you need to because if you're seriously
going to engage with an Adventist on
this stuff you have to understand the
system and how each piece
fits breaking that down takes time I I
try to do my best to be concise but I
also have to be thorough
the these presentations are not for you
to just have information to store in
your head it is to help you the believer
better understand what we're dealing
with
here this is a very carefully crafted
deception that as a system is leading
millions of people to
predition we do not want this we care
about
Adventists but this system is a
deception and Adventists need warned
about that and if you're going to reach
them it requires some rigor and and some
real work to really understand what's
being said both in scripture and by
their framework of theology to then be
able to effectively reach them but I
hope that some of you are starting to
get a better grasp on the
interconnectedness of this system and
how dependent each belief
is on other beliefs in the
system Advent that you run into that do
this sort of allart style adventism
they're either unaware of how all this
fits together
and the necessity of it
all or they are and they just don't care
which means that they're really being
dishonest what Steven bour provided for
us was once again another example of how
Adventist theology operates Hopscotch
your way around the Bible citing various
proof texts followed by lots of
assertions from the great controversy
worldview and that's how adventism
operates I don't care if it's The Old
Paths types like Steven or the Neo
Adventist types like Tim Gillespie or
the alleged gospel Adventist of the
movement all of adventism is Unified by
their shared worldview and there is no
getting around
this you can try and reject the
investigative judgment 1844 Ellen White
do this allaart style approach but that
only creates more problems so if that's
you it is time to reconsider your
affiliation with this organization that
is actively under the curse of God and
is an enemy of the true Christ and his
gospel May Christ richly bless you in
the grace and peace won by him and his
vicarious death on the cross for Sinners
Hallelujah and Marin AA
[Music]